GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
OF FOR THE CONNECTING THE CENSUS
TO CALIFORNIANS THE WHOLE THE
ROLES OF NONPROFITS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
I JOIN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
TWENTY TWENTY STE.
UNITED STATES CENSUS VIA SOME
THAT THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE NONPROFIT SECTOR --
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MONIQUE LIMON
WHO SUGGESTED THAT THE CENSUS
SELECT COMMITTEES HOLD A HEARING
WITH THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR.
AND ALSO THANK DOCTOR RICHARD
PAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AS CHAIR
OF THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE TWENTY TWENTY UNITED
STATES CENSUS.
IN MAY THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE SET US CENSUS SO I
COMMITTEES CONVENED A JOINT
HEARING ABOUT MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
INCLUDING UNDER FUNDING THIS
SHIFT TO INTERNET DATA
COLLECTION AND CUTBACKS IN FIELD
TESTING CYBERSECURITY CONCERNS.
AND THE INCLUSION OF A
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION AND THE AND
THE POSSIBLE INCLUSION OF A
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION ALL REMAIN
OPTIMISTIC.
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS IS A
TOP PRIORITY PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND WE PLAN TO DO EVERYTHING WE
NEED TO TO ENSURE A COMPLETE
COUNT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE ORGANIZING EARLIER THAN
EVER BEFORE WITH MORE FUNDING
AND BETTER COORDINATION THAN
WE'VE EVER HAD.
THE STATE IS INVESTING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. FOR OUR REGION
EDUCATION AND HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES.
THE STATE IS INVESTING --
WE'RE LOOKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION CENSUS DIRECTOR
DID ESCHATOLOGY AND GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY SECRETARY.
MARIBEL BATTER.
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
GOV OPS IS THE LEAD AGENCY
TASKED WITH DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN FOR THE NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS.
DEDICATED FOR OUR REGION
EDUCATION.
I ALSO WANT RECOGNIZE DEPUTY
SECRETARY GOT CUNNINGHAM MORTON
FROM GOV OPS WHO HAS JOINED US
HERE TODAY --
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
TODAY'S BRIEFING WILL INCLUDE
EXPERT TESTIMONY TO HELP INFORM
THE STATE'S PLANNING EFFORTS.
SPECIFICALLY WATER LOCAL COUNTY
AND CITY GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS
AND PHILANTHROPY DOING
INDIVIDUALLY AND COLLECTIVELY TO
FORMULATE PLANS AND MOBILIZE
RESOURCES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW CAN THESE EFFORTS BE
COORDINATED AT A LOCAL REGIONAL
AND STATEWIDE LEVEL AND BE
INTEGRATED WITH THE STATE PLAN?
WE ALSO WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
COMMON STRATEGIES AND BEST
PRACTICES AND ABOUT HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NON PROFITS AND
PHILANTHROPY ARE ALREADY
COLLABORATING --
ARE ARE ALREADY COLLABORATIVELY
PLANNING TOGETHER.
WERE ALSO INTERESTED IN HEARING
ABOUT STRATEGIES TO AVOID
DUPLICATION AND OVERLAP OF
SPENDING IN CONTRACTING.
AND WE WANNA LEARN WHAT ACTIONS
STATE GOVERNMENT SHOULD TAKE TO
BE INEFFECTIVE CENSUS PARTNER
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT NON
PROFITS AND PHILANTHROPY.
WE KNOW THAT A ONE PLAN FITS ALL
APPROACH WILL NOT WORK FOR ARE
NEVER STATE BUT WE THINK IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYONE IS ON THE SAME PAGE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
HEARINGS TO BE SURE THAT WE ARE
ON TRACK TO GET EVERYONE
COUNTED.
TWENTY TWENTY WE ONLY HAVE ONE
CHANCE OF THIS DECADE TO GET
THIS RIGHT.
WE HAVE ONLY THREE WEEKS LEFT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO COMPLETE
ITS BUSINESS FOR THE YEAR
pTIME WITH THE MAN'S ON
LEGISLATORS IN ALL DIRECTIONS SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE.
MARKET RIGHT NOW AND ALSO WILL
JOIN US THROUGHOUT THE MORNING
AND FOR THOSE WISHING TO MAKE A
BRIEF PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR PANELS.
THERE'S A SIGN IN SHEET WITH THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS I'LL NOW TURN
IT OVER TO THE OTHER CHAIRS TO
MAKE OPENING REMARKS --
SOME REAL AMONG.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER UP BERMAN AND AT SENATOR
UP PAN FOR IT FOR COMING
TOGETHER TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
IN MY ROLE AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR.
AND I KNOW THAT NOT ONLY MYSELF
BUT SO MANY NON PROFITS IN THE
STATE HAVE BEEN TRACKING THAT
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS CLOSELY.
ON THE CONVERSATIONS THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE RISEN --
FROM POTENTIAL CHANGES HAVE BEEN
SOME THAT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
--
HAS BEEN FOLLOWING CLOSELY
TENTATIVELY AT TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE BEST WAYS
TO MOVE FORWARD.
I LIKE MANY OF YOU AND MANY
COLLEAGUES AND REPRESENT.
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE SOME AREAS
THAT ARE HARD TO COUNT --
AND THOSE --
THIS THOUGH SINCE THE TRACKS ARE
NOT UNIQUE BUT THEY'RE REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR EXAMPLE I
IN THE AREA THAT I REPRESENT TO
HAVE THE ISLA VISTA AND THE THAT
YOU SEE SP COMMUNITY WHERE WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS AND WHO.
AT MIGHT BE UNDERCOUNTED AND AS
A MATTER OF FACT IN TWENTY TEN
THEY WERE UNDERCOUNTED AND WE
HAVE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
DISTRICTS WHERE THAT REPRESENT
90% HISPANIC LATINO.
AND IN ONLY 6280% OF THOSE I
HOUSEHOLDS ME INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY THRESHOLDS SO YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW WE GET
INFORMATION TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT MOST.
AND NEED THE INFORMATION BUT
ALSO THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
AND DESERVE TO BE COUNTED WE'VE
HAD PASSED CHALLENGES AND AS
I'VE IDENTIFIED AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN TWENTY TWENTY WERE
SEEN THAT WE MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES I'M AND ROAD BLOCKS.
AND THAT HAVE BEEN PUT BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IN THAT
MEANS THAT THE ROLE OF ALL OF US
AS A LEGISLATURE AS MEMBERS AS
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
BUT ALSO THE ENTITIES INVOLVED
IN TODAY'S CONVERSATION ARE
GONNA PLAY AN EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT ROLE AND I IT IS CLEAR
TO ME THAT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
WHO HAS THE CAPACITY TO TOUCH
LIVES IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA RURAL
URBAN SUB URBAN.
AND IS REALLY AN ENTITY THAT --
CAN HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGE CHALLENGES AT THE
FOURTH LARGEST --
EMPLOYER --
ARE INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INTO NON PROFITS TO
BE ABLE TO AT WORK WITH US AND
TO ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING AND
HEARING FROM OUR PRESENTERS FROM
OUR PANELISTS FROM COLLEAGUES A
IN OR AS WE PREPARE AND AS A
STATE TO DETERMINE HOW BEST TO
ROLL OUT.
A THE CENSUS OR OUTREACH WORK
THAT WE PLAN ON DOING AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH NONPROFIT AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT NEXT WE HAVE I THINK SENATOR
PAT WHO IS GOING TO OPEN UP AND
SAY SOME WORDS AND SO THANK YOU
SENATOR.
A THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A GOOD MORNING --
FIRST OF ALL WELCOME EVERYONE
HERE WHY THINK --
GOV OPS FOR YOUR INVESTMENT IN
MAKING THE CENSUS A SUCCESS AND
FOR BEING HERE TODAY I ALSO I
THANK ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS.
TO OUR TRAVEL TO MAKE TIME TO BE
HERE SO WE CAN BE EDUCATED ON
SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES
MOVING FORWARDS.
AND HOPEFULLY --
AVOID LOT THAT FALLS IS --
SO MEMBER --
CHAIR BERMAN SAID THAT WE HAVE
WELL BASICALLY YOU HAVE ONE SHOT
EVERY TEN YEARS ON THE CENSUS --
IT'S ALSO EXCITING SEE SO MANY
PEOPLE ENGAGED IN THE CENSUS
EFFORTS AND I THINK ALL THE
AUDIENCE MEMBERS HERE AND TO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING
ONLINE.
NO I CAME FROM THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR ICE --
AND CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE
UNITED WAY BOARD HERE IN --
AND AND SACRAMENTO SERVED ON
OTHER I ALSO SERVED ON A FIRST
FIVE COMMISSION AS WELL AND I
KNOW THE IMPORTANT ROLE NON
PROFITS --
PLAY AND I'LL BE TRUSTED MANAGE
OUR TRUSTED MESSENGER SO THE
COMMUNITY REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
S. SOME MEMBERS AMOUNT AND PASS
USE CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
NONPROFIT SECTOR REACHED OUT TO
CENTER BERMAN AND I SAY THAT WE
NEED TO EARLY ON HAVE THIS
HEARING AND TALK ABOUT THE ROLE.
NOT PROFITS CAN PLAY AND NO
SOONER BERMAN I HAVE BEEN HAVING
MANY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW DO
WE REACH OUT TO BE SURE WE CAN
GET EVERYONE TOWN IN ONE OF
THOSE REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS IS
THAT WE DO NEED TO BE SURE THAT.
PEOPLE HERE FROM TRUSTED
MESSENGERS THERE'S GOING TO
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT DIFFERENT THINGS RELATE
THE CENSUS.
AND WE ARE ACTUALLY CONCERNED
THAT THEIR UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE GONNA BE PEOPLE WHO MADE THE
INTEREST THEN EVEN UNDERMINING
OF THE CENSUS AND AND SENDING.
MIXED MESSAGES ABOUT ABOUT THIS
I EVEN RIGHT NOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH A COURT CASE AROUND THE
QUESTIONS THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION WHICH I WAS NOT
RESEARCH STAND AS INDICATED AND
SEEMS ARE.
AND DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN REVEALED
SO FAR THAT THERE MAY BEEN
POLITICAL MOTIVES BUT ULTIMATELY
ARE THE FOUNDERS OUR COUNTRY --
BUT IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT WE
NEED TO THE CENSUS EVERY TEN
YEARS AND WAS VERY CLEAR THAT
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE COUNTED FOR
THE CENSUS.
AND SO IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WE NEED TO BE SURE RESOURCES AND
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO NON
PROFITS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO BE SURE THAT
WE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
SMALLER NON PROFITS AND CAMILLE
LEADERS --
WHO MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE THE
ONES THAT?
HAVE THE KIND OF SERVE.
FISCAL CAPACITY THAT USUALLY
INTERFACES OF GOVERNMENT BUT
HAVE THAT CREDIBILITY WITH A
VERY POPULATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
REACH OUT TO SO WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE BUILD THOSE
BRIDGES BETWEEN --
IN THE CENSUS WHICH IS AN
OPERATION FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WHETHER STATE GOVERNMENT WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH LARGE
NONPROFITS THEN WITH THE WITH AT
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT A
WORK OUT AS WE APPROACH HOW THE
CENSUS AND TWENTY TWENTY SO
PROUD AND I CONTINUE BE
ENTHUSIASTIC CLAP OF WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE.
AND THIS HEARING WILL BETTER
INFORM EXACTLY HOW WE CAN
FURTHER ENHANCES SUPPORT THE
MUTUAL EFFORTS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE COUNT EVERYONE FOR
THE CENSUS.
SO WITH THAT LIKE OF A FEW
LOGISTICS BEFORE WE START A
FIRST PANEL --
EACH SPEAKER WILL HAVE ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES.
QUESTION ANSWER SESSION WHERE --
THE SPEAKERS THAT WILL NOT BE
TIME MY STAFFER HERE AS GOING
THE WHOLE TIME CARD SO JUST TO
GIVES OF GIVE YOU SOME FEEDBACK
ON THE TIME.
OF BECAUSE OF THE FLOOR SESSION.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THERE IS
THAT WILL HAVE LIMITED TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE DO HAVE A
SIGN IN SHEET AS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY THE SERGEANT SO IF
YOU ARE ACTUALLY MAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE SIGN IN.
THE SERGEANTS.
WHEN YOU GET THERE --
WILL GET THE PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
TRY TO KEEP PUBLIC COMMENT TO A
MINUTE HOWEVER IF YOU DO WISH TO
MAKE LARGER LONGER COMMENTS ARE
YOU CAN SUBMIT THOSE IN WRITING.
AND OUT PLEASE SEND THOSE AYE
VIA EMAIL TO A LESSER CHRIS AND
THAT THE EMAILS ARE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE GENDER SO IF
YOU'RE.
SO DESERVE HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS IN
YOUR SPOKEN REMARKS BUT YOU
SHOULD FEEL FREE TO SEND LARGER
LONGER REMARKS OUT BY EMAIL.
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST
PANEL.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN THE --
WITH -- SO
BOTH LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE ESTABLISHED THE
LOCAL COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE
AND A VERY DOWN A LOT OF
PLANNING AND HARD WORK PREPARE
FOR TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
WE HOPE THEY DRAW FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCES IN PAST CENSUSES TO
GAIN A BETTER IDEA OF THE
CURRENT EFFORTS NOT ONLY TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN ASSIST
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO SERVE
AS ROLE MODELS FOR OTHER
COUNTIES.
FIND BUT TOGETHER DEAR CENSUS
PLANTS.
SO I'M HAPPY THAT --
TO INTRODUCE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PANEL --
FEATURING OUT THERE TO BE A PART
OF FROM LOS ANGELES AND ADRIAN
PUN.
OUT FROM THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRAN.
YOU FOR HELPING US KICK OFF THAT
ARE HEARING TODAY IN AND QUICKLY
BEFORE YOU ALL GET STARTED AS
ONE RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE JONES
SAWYER --
AND SEE IF YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
OPENING REMARKS.
AND OUT OF BE BRIEF --
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
AS I FROM THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THAT HAD.
THE WORST UNDERCOUNT.
NOT IN THE STATE'S WITNESSES
STREAMING IMPORTANT TO ME BOB
AND I'M GOING TO ADVOCATE.
AS EACH PANEL COMES UP TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT DOING THINGS OUT OF
THE BOX.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE GOING AFTER
LATINO CAUGHT AFRICAN AMERICAN%
COUNT ARE LIKE IN MY DISTRICT
HOMELESS IN ON UNDOCUMENTED?
WE JUST CAN'T SEE IT SEND.
BECKY INBEV.
THESE WHITE PEOPLE TO THE TO THE
DOORS KNOCKING WOULDA.
WHAT IPAD ASKING THEM
[inaudible] TO GOING TO THEIR
HOMES AND ASK HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE THERE IT JUST WE JUST CAN'T
CONTINUE. TO DO TO STAY IN
TRADITIONAL THING EXPECTED
DIFFERENT ARM RESULT INSULT OUT
REACH AND HOW WE DO IT AND DO IT
DIFFERENTLY ARM.
WHETHER YOU YOU HAVE MARIACHIS
AND MOTOWN MUSIC I DON'T CARE.
WHETHER IT.
A BARBECUE I DON'T CARE.
QUITE IS SALSA OR ELECTRIC SLIDE
WHAT EVER WE NEED TO DO TO GET
THEM OUT AND GET THAT COUNT AS
ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW MY COMMUNITY LOT OF
COMMUNITIES.
THEY MAY NOT SHOW UP. TO ONE OF
THESE HEARINGS OR TO A VERY STE.
DATE KIND OF FAIR SENSES FAIR.
BUT YOU PUT AFFAIRS WILL OUT
THERE.
YOU MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE SHOW UP
AND YOU AND I'M WILLING TO PUSH
THE ENVELOPE.
EVEN IF.
EVEN IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MAY NOT LIKE IT WOULD IN MAYBE
THE STATE NEEDS TO LOOK AT HOW
WE CAN DO THAT INVEST IN IT SO
WE GET MORE PEOPLE. TO BE
INVESTED IN COMING FORTH AND
GETTING THAT ACCURATE COUNT SO
--
I'M.
WHAT NEED HURDLES UNIQUE IDEAS
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER RIGHTS
MAYBE ONE BRIEF MARK BEFORE WE
START PANEL RELATION TO THAT?
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT ACTUALLY
THE CENSUS ENDS IN A FEW MONTHS
ACTUALLY MAYBE I THINK THE START
PRETTY SOON THERE'LL BE HIRING
PEOPLE COULD BE AT NUMERATORS.
THEY'RE GONNA BE HIRING PEOPLE
IN NEW REYES NOW THEY'RE GONNA
PUT OUT A JOB THAT ENTIRE
PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S PART OF OUR JOB
HERE -- TO
BE SURE WEGET AYE DIVERSE POOL
OF PEOPLE APPLYING FOR THIS JOB
SO THAT THE PERSONS KNOCKING ON
THE DOOR IS ACTUALLY FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
AND SO I JUST GOT PUT THAT OUT
THERE OUT BECAUSE TALK IT SENSES
MAYBE TWENTY TWENTY BUT ARE
GONNA BE HIRING SOON AND PERHAPS
NAY SUMMER PALACE CAN SPEAK TO
THAT AS WELL BUT WHAT WE CAN TRY
TO DO.
AT EVERY STAGE ALL THE UP TO THE
SENSES BUT BEING SURE THAT WE
ALSO HAVE ENUMERATORS --
TO REFLECT THE COMMUTE OUR
COMMUNITIES.
RESPONSE REYES WELL SO WELL WITH
THAT --
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THAT -- IS
MISS PARK IN MOURNING.
SO GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DOROTHY A PARK AND
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
I'M THE MANAGER OF THE CENSUS.
FOR LA COUNTY'S CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART
OF TODAY'S CONVERSATION.
SO IN TERMS OF CROSS SECTOR
COORDINATION LOCALLY REGIONALLY
STATEWIDE THAT'S BEEN THE
CORNERSTONE PRISON CAMP IN THE
COUNTY OF LA AND IT STARTED WITH
THE LOCAL UPDATED CENSUS
ADDRESSES.
WE GOT EIGHTY EIGHT CITY
PARTNERS TO COLLECT THEIR
ADDRESSES WE ACTUALLY PARTNERED
WITH COMMUNITY CONNECT LABS WHO
WORRY HELPED US ORGANIZE
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS IN UNIONS. TO
FIND THE NON STANDARD ADDRESSES
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN
BASEMENTS WHO ARE LIVING IN
TRAILERS WERE LIVING IN A NON
STANDARD UNCONVENTIONAL WAY.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO COLLECT OVER
FOUR THOUSAND OF THESE
NONSTANDARD ADDRESSES JUST
WITHIN FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
HARD TO SURVEY BLOCK GROUPS.
AND THAT WAS DONE WITH THE F. --
EFFORT AND SUPPORT OF OUR OFFICE
OF IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
WHOSE HERE TODAY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ARE EFFORT IN LA COUNTY RESULTED
IN OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADDRESSES BEING SENT TO THE US
CENSUS BURKE BEYOND NEW
ADDRESSES TO BE CONSIDERED. TO
BE ADDED.
ADDITIONALLY AT THE LAST JOINT
SELECT COMMITTEE I SPOKE ABOUT
WANTING TO HAVE AN ANTELOPE
VALLEY CONVENING AND WE DID PULL
IT OFF -- WE
PARTNERED AGAIN WITH C. C.
AFTER.
TO DO THAT AND SAC STATE
PROVIDED US WITH THE MATERIALS
AND THE CENSUS DIRECTOR CAME
ALONG WITH THE US CENSUS BUREAU
NO WAY OUT.
AND SEE PAN ARE --
SINCE ITS POLICY ADVOCATES SEEN
THAT ALSO LOCAL BUSINESS
PARTNERS UP IN THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY SO WE ARE VERY ENGAGED
IN.
CREATING THESE PARTNERSHIPS.
SO WE HAVE THREE COMPLETE CAO
COMMITTEES ARE COUNTY WIDE
OUTREACH COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEE
IS CO CHAIR WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND WHAT WE HAVE THERE
IS THIS -- A
SEVERAL SUBCOMMITTEES ONE BEING
A STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY TABLE
WITH C. PAN.
THROUGH THE ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
AND SUPPORTED BY CCF AND IT IS A
GROWING NETWORK OF CBS AND FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH A WE
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
SOUTHEAST LA COLLABORATIVE ON
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENTS A
STRATEGIES.
ANOTHER GROUP WE WORK WITH OF
COURSE ARE EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES
AND WE WORK WITH THEM THROUGH
OUR COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS.
ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE IS HIGHER
EDUCATION WHICH WAS MENTIONED
HERE EARLIER.
WE HAVE ORGANIZED COMMUNITY
STATE AND YOU THE UC LA AS WELL
AS PRIVATE.
UNIVERSITIES TO PARTICIPATE BOTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND STUDENTS ARE
ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE
STUDENTS KNOW HOW TO REACH
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS ARE THE
HARDEST TO COUNT POCKET ONE OF
THE HARDEST CAN'T POPULATIONS.
NATIONWIDE.
AND THE GOAL IS TO NOT ONLY
ENCOURAGE THEM TO COMPLETE THE
SURVEY BUT ALSO VOLUNTEER AS
CENSUS GOODWILL AMBASSADORS
MOVING FORWARD.
ANOTHER GROUP THAT WE'VE ENGAGED
THIS LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS THEY COVER THIRTY ONE
OF OUR COUNTY CITIES.
THEY ALSO HAVE PRESCHOOL ADULT
EDUCATION AND NUMEROUS OTHER
PROGRAMS WE ARE TYING IN WITH
THEIR WE ARE ONE PROGRAM WHICH
WAS FOR THEIR IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
--
IN DEVELOPING A DISTRICT WIDE
STRATEGIES AND WE HOPE TO SHARE
EIGHTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN LA COUNTY.
SO THAT THEY HAVE A MENU OF
OPTIONS TO SELECT FROM IN
PROMOTING THE CENSUS.
ANOTHER GROUP THAT WE HAVE BEEN
MEETING WITH IS SEIU THAT SIXTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALONE AND THEY ARE EAGER
TO PARTICIPATE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
AND WE ARE JUST STARTING TO
ORGANIZE AROUND BUSINESSES IN
CHAMBERS.
AND ONE FINAL GROUP THAT WE'VE
WORKED WITH STARTED TO WORK WITH
OUR UNIVERSITIES AND MEDIA --
TO BEGIN TO CREATE A VOICE
AROUND THE IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THE CENSUS AND
ACHIEVING A COMPLETE CAO.
PART TWO OTHER COMPLETE CAO
COMMUNITY CARE COMMITTEES EXCUSE
ME OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AND TRANSPORTATION.
THEY FOCUS AND BRING FOR TO THE
FOREFRONT THE PERSONAL BENEFITS
A PARTICIPATING IN THE CENSUS.
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL WE TALKED
BY WEEKLY WITH THE CITY OF LA
WITH SACRAMENTO SAN MATEO AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING
IN THE STATE WHY CONVENIENCE AND
THEN THE SWORD MAPPING TOOL
DEVELOPMENT.
WITH STUDENTS BEING ONE OF THE
HARDEST TO SURVEY POPULATIONS
WEAVING GAUGE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND A DISCUSSION TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
ADDING AN OPT IN IN COMPLETING
THEIR REGISTRATION.
DURING THE REGISTRATION PROCESS
TO COMPLETE THE CENSUS SURVEY
AND WE'RE HOPING WE GET YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE CONTINUE
TO PARTICIPATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
IN OUR STRATEGIES.
SO THE COMMON STRATEGIES I'M
GONNA TELL YOU IS START NOW AND
DEVELOP A COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE IF YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR
COUNTIES AND PARTNER WITH YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS.
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH THE MAPPING
TOOLS THAT TELL YOU WHERE THE
HARD TO SURVEY POPULATIONS ARE
WE'RE USING THE STATEWIDE AS
THREE BASE MAPPING TOOL THAT WE
ALSO USE BY BLOCK GROUP.
AND WE WANT TO PARTNER AND WE
ARE PARTNERING WITH CCC'S CBO'S
AND NGOS.
ON THE SOARED SYSTEM AND WE'RE
DOING A AND ADOPT A BLOCK GROUP
PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE FOCUSING ON HARD TO
SURVEY POPULATIONS BY GEOGRAPHY
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
ALSO POPULATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ADOPTED.
THAT MAY NOT BE IN A GEOGRAPHY
SUCH AS NATIVE AMERICANS
VETERANS AND LGBTQ COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO FINDING
SOLUTIONS AND FILLING GAPS WITH
OUR SENSES GOODWILL AMBASSADORS
ARE VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS IN
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE VOLUNTEERS
MOBILIZING COLLEGE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN UNIONS.
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
IMPLEMENTING SECT CENSUS ACTION
KIOSKS TO PROVIDE OUR
POPULATIONS WITH THE VENUE WITH
IN LANGUAGE INFORMATION
TRANSLATION SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE IN COMPLETING THE
SURVEY.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WE TRAIN.
OUR CCC'S R. CBO'S ARE EMPLOYEES
AND OUR AND NGOS IN OUTREACH
MESSAGING.
SO THINGS THAT WE WANT TO AVOID
IN DUPLICATING OF APRS IN
AVOIDING GAPS WE WANT ALL BE
USING THAT SORT SYSTEM. TO
LOCATE OUR SENSES ACTION KIOSKS
AND TO LOCATE OUR C. BE ADOPTED
BLOCK GROUPS.
AND THAT'LL HELP US AVOID UP
CREATING GAPS BECAUSE IF THERE
ARE GAPS WE WILL FILL THOSE IN
WITH MUNICIPALITIES UNIONS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. ONE
AREA I WOULD LIKE YOU FOLKS TO
CONSIDER ADDRESSING GOING
FORWARD ALONG WITH US IS THE
DEVELOP DEVELOPMENT OF A
MECHANISM.
THAT SHARES THE CENSUS BUREAU
THE STATE THE CBO'S AND NGOS
RESEARCH AND DATA FROM VARIOUS
FOCUS GROUPS AND OTHER TESTING
METHODOLOGIES TO HELP ESTABLISH
THE SURROUND SOUND MESSAGING AND
POOLING OF EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES.
THAT RESONATE WITH HARD TO
SURVEY POPULATIONS.
IF YOU OR YOUR STAFF WOULD LIKE
ADDITIONALINFORMATION ABOUT LA
COUNTY I'D BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH
YOU THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE ON THE PANEL TO TAKE
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
PLANNING EFFORT TO THE NEXT STEP
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS PARK --
MS POND.
UP THAT MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY'S HEARING
FINANCING DREW UPON I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE OFFICE OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS
PRETTY SITTING COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE ARE A POLICY GRANT
MAKING DIRECT SERVICING CLIENTS
OFFICE THAT PROVIDES OVER FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN IMMIGRANT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PROJECTS --
WE WORK WITH LOW INCOME PUBLIC
HOUSING AND IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS WE OPERATE THREE
PUBLIC PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INITIATIVES THE SAN FRANCISCO
PATHWAYS TO CITIZENSHIP DREAM
SFL A SHIP AND A COMMUNITY
AMBASSADORS SAFETY A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
MANY OF THESE PROJECTS INVOLVE
FROM OUR WORK DURING THE TWENTY
TEN CENSUS WE ARE A ONE OF ABOUT
TWENTY IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS OFFICES
IN THE COUNTRY WE COORDINATE
WITH OTHER CITIES AND STATES.
AND WE WILL BE OVERSEEING THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS EFFORT FOR
SAN FRANCISCO LIKE MANY
JURISDICTIONS SEPARATE CISCO HAS
UNIQUE CHALLENGES HIGH DENSITY
HIGH NUMBER OF NONTRADITIONAL
AND RECORDED OR LOW VISIBILITY
HOUSING.
WITH ONE OF THE HIGHEST HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS IN THE STATE
AND NATIONALLY.
A ONE IN EVERY THREE RESIDENCES
EVER.
ON THE LEVEL OF DIVERSE CITY
WITH SIGNIFICANT --
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR NEARLY HALF OF OUR
POPULATION SPEAKS A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AT HOME IF YOU ADD TO THAT OVER
13% OF OUR POPULATION LACKS
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
THERE'S A HUGE DIGITAL DIVIDE
PARTICULARLY FOR SENIORS LOW
INCOME.
MONOLINGUAL LDAP HOUSEHOLDS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OUR
APPROACH TO THE SENSES FOCUSES
ON STREET SMART RELEVANT
GRASSROOTS OUTREACH CLOSE
COLLABORATION AND CROSS SECTION
WITH THAT OF CROSS SECTION OF
BOUGHT CITY NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED FOUNDATION BUSINESS
EDUCATION LABOR PARTNERS.
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT AND
REFLECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TWENTY TEN OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
DIVIDED THE CITY INTO EIGHT HARD
TO COUNT AREAS WITH TARGETED
APPROACHES IN EACH WHILE
CONDUCTING A CITY WIDE GENERAL
STYLE SENSES CAMPAIGN.
WE FORMED A DIVERSE TWENTY FIVE
MEMBER CROSS SECTOR COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE THAT COORDINATE
WELL WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS COMMISSION AND
THE MANY.
COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEES
PERFORMED ACROSS THE CITY
FUNDING WAS COORDINATED WITH
FIVE LOCAL FOUNDATIONS IN THE
CITY PROVIDED NOBODY HAD ANY
MONEY OUT IN TWENTY CHEN.
SO WE PROVIDE AT SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TEMPLATES UP THE HOPE FOR DEEP
GRANTS R. P. AND CRITERIA.
A WEEK QUARTERLY TRAINING
SESSIONS AND MONTHLY EVENTS
PARTNER WITH OTHER BAY AREA
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
FOUNDATIONS ARE MAPPING ASSURING
TRACKING TOOLS TO MONITOR
RESPONSE RATES BY CENSUS TRACTS
--
ALSO THIS MAY SOUND LIKE AN
ANTITHESIS TO THE CENSUS BUT WE
TRY TO BUILD A SENSE OF FUN AND
PURPOSE.
OUGHT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THIS REAL RELEVANT FOR PEOPLE SO
WE APPLIED CREATIVITY TO THE
OUTREACH FOR INSTANCE IN THE
MISSION DISTRICT.
COMMUNITY GROUPS PARTNER ON A
PHOTO NOVELLA THAT START SOME OF
OUR OWN EMPLOYEES AND IT REACH
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THEY ALSO
HELD A SOCCER MATCH.
THAT ATTRACTED OVER ONE THOUSAND
CENSUS PARTICIPANTS IN A SINGLE
EVENT INTO TENDERLOIN ONE OF THE
SMALLEST GRANTS ARE NOT
SUPPORTED AND INFO BOOTH AT THE
TET FESTIVAL WHICH DREW. TEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS WE USE OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT RESOURCES
TO DEPLOY OUR OWN GROUND CREW OF
A HUNDRED TWENTY RESIDENTS TO
CONDUCT DAILY OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
HOUSING SRO AND SECTION EIGHT
RESIDENTS.
WHO REFLECT AT THE ACTUAL
POPULATION THAT WE WERE TRYING
TO REACH OUT TO A LARGELY
IMMIGRANTS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN A
AND THAT TINO COMMUNITIES THE
CHINA TOWN OF THE FEW AREAS TWO
OF THE HARDEST? TO COUNT AREAS
OF THE CITY IMPROVE BY 10% OR
MORE IN THEIR RESPONSE RATES --
AND THIS WAS DIDN'T EXCUSE ME
ALL DUE TO THE WORK OF OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE TRANSFORM
THE TO FIELD TEAM INTO A HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL ONGOING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
POST SENSES A DOZEN OF THE
WORKERS ARE STILL WORKING TODAY
AND EMPLOYED FULL TIME AS CITY
EMPLOYEES OTHERS THIRTY OF THEM
ALL OVER THE CITY WORKING HOT
SPOT.
TRANSIT BUSINESS UP QUARTERS OF
THE CITY SO BY INVESTING ARE
LIMITED DOLLARS IN EFFORTS IT
DIDN'T DUPLICATE THE MAINSTREAM.
OF MASS MEDIA EFFORTS AND
OUTREACH BY THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU WE WERE THE ONLY COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA WHOSE
PARTICIPATION RATES REMAIN
STEADY AND APPROVED AND ALL
EIGHT HARD TO COUNT.
AREAS A WE WERE EVER BUILT ON
THAT --
EFFORT AND THE TURNED THE SIONIS
SUSTAINABLE PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES SO CONCLUSION --
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENSURING
RESOURCES AND TRAINING AT THE
FRONT END AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT
GRANT FUNDS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THIS IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL EFFORT.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT GAPS AREAS
THE STATE THEATER UNDER COUNTED
UNDER RESOURCE AND THAT REGIONAL
LOCAL AREAS TAYLOR DE APPROACHES
FOUNDATIONS CAN BE HELPFUL IN
DETERRENCE SEARCHING GETTING
RESOURCES TO AREAS WITH THE
LEASE.
CAPACITY INFRASTRUCTURE TO FILL
GAPS ARE AND FINALLY WE HOPE
THAT THE STATE'S PLAN WILL ALLOW
CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH THE
CAPACITY TO MANAGE THEIR OWN
COORDINATED TARGET LARGE SCALE
GRANTS EFFORT.
WE NEED STATE FUNDS FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND TO TRAIN CITIES
AND COUNTIES OUT WHO ARE KEY
POINTS OF COORDINATION YOU HAVE
TO HELP THE LOCAL PRESENT LICK
LINKING PRESENTS LINKING THE
EFFORT --
AND TAILORED APPROACH IS AN HOUR
AND SHARING INFORMATION BEST
PRACTICES WITH OTHER COUNTIES SO
SAN FRANCISCO WILL BE ALLOWED
LAUNCHING OUR COMPLETE CAO
COMMITTEE AND GRANTS PROGRAM IN
NEXT MONTH.
OUR FOCUS IS ON TECH AND DIGITAL
APPLICATIONS TRAINING MULTI
LINGUAL MULTICULTURAL AND
NONTRADITIONAL OUTREACH WE
ALREADY HAVE THAT OUR YOUNG
RAPPER IDENTIFIED TO BE THE FACE
OF OUR TWENTY TWENTY SENSES.
A WEEK AT FORT TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE ON THIS EFFORT THANK
YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND WITH THAT MONTH TURNED OVER
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THEY HAVE
[inaudible]
THE PANELISTS A COUPLE QUESTIONS
--
AND AND YOU BOTH UC IT TOUCHED
UPON THIS A LITTLE BIT --
IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS BUT NOT.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS BOTH FOR
YOU'VE LEARNED?
THEN PRIOR ATTEMPTS AND ALSO
JUST THE HOW TECHNOLOGY HAS
CHANGED TE MEASURE AND OR THE
KIND OF TOWARDS MEASURING AND
REPORTING THE REACH IMPACT --
IN AREAS OF NEED IN YOUR AVERAGE
EFFORTS SO HOW.
YOU KNOW.
THIS STATE IS VERY EAGER TO
SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS AND WERE
ABLE TO GET A LOT OF MONEY IN
THE BUDGET THE MAIN THING THAT I
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES LAWS
ADVOCATING FOR THAT INCREASE
FUNDING WAS HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE
THAT.
WERE ACTUALLY TRACKING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OF THE EFFORTS
--
AND CHANGING TACK IF NEED BE IF
IF EFFORTS ARE INEFFECTIVE --
SAID.
ANY THOUGHTS OR ADVICE YOU HAVE
ON ON HOW TO DO THAT.
SO WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING IS
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT O IS OUR
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY GROUPS.
AND THEIR INDICATING TO US WHAT
AREAS THEY CAN COVER THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS AS WELL AS
THE CITIES.
ARE WHERE LITERALLY GONNA BE
MAPPING THE BLOCK GROUPS THAT
THEY CAN COVER AND WHERE WE HAVE
GAPS FORGET IDENTIFY THOSE EARLY
ENOUGH SO THAT WE CAN GET.
THE KIND OF VOLUNTEERS WHETHER
IT'S YOU KNOW COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ARE CITY EMPLOYEES IN PLACE TO
FILL THOSE GAPS --
OR WHETHER THEY'RE ANY NEW
BREEDERS THAT ARE HIRED THREE
THE CENSUS BUREAU ALTHOUGH.
THOSE AYE ENUMERATORS DO REQUIRE
A CITIZENSHIP WHICH IS NEW
CORRECT WELL IT'S DIFFERENT FROM
LAST.
YEAR.
LAST TIME THERE WAS A WAIVER SO
YEAH BASICALLY --
YEAH WE REALIZE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THESE OTHER
RESOURCES AS WELL SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE LITERALLY.
GOING THROUGH --
EACH OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES
THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THEM BY BLOCK
GROUP TO MAKE CERTAIN WE HAVE
COVERAGE CREDIT.
UP DURING THE TWENTY TEN SENSES
WE DID APPLY NUMBER OF METRICS
AT THE FRONT END OF OUR EFFORT
M. OUT PARTNER ITH OTHER CITIES
BECAUSE NOT EVERYBODY HAD THE
SAME CAPACITY YOUR RESOURCES.
AND WE USE A COMMON TRACKING TO
WILL SO WE EIGHT WERE ABLE TO
MONITOR RESPONSE RATES BY CENSUS
TRACKS IN EACH OF OUR AREAS AND
IN ANY TIME YOU DID AN ACTIVITY
TO SEE IF THAT.
THERE WAS AN UP TICK IN OF THE
RESPONSE RATE FOR THIS TYPE OF
GO AROUND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PUT THEM EMPLOY OTHER --
NOT ONLY THAT EFFORT BUT MY
SUGGESTION TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THE STATE IS MAKE
GOOD FRIENDS WITH YOUR PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY WERE MY
LIFE SAVERS YOU KNOW THEY DID A
LOT OF THE DEEP DIVE INTO THE
CENSUS TRACTS TICKET TELL ME
EXACTLY WHERE.
WE NEED IT TICKLE SO WE COULD
DEPLOY OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
THOSE PARTS OF THE CITY WHERE WE
KNEW WITH THE RESPONSE RATE WAS
IN A WORKING --
SO I THINK HAVING TECHNOLOGY
TRAINING YOU KNOW BECAUSE THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN ALL DIGITAL US CENSUS
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONCERNS WE
HAVE.
FOR THE HARD TO COUNT AREAS OF
THE CITY WHERE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO SMARTPHONES THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE INTERNET OR CABLE IN
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS SO YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT REALISTIC WAYS. TO
HELP THEM PARTICIPATE AND THOSE
ARE.
REALLY HELPFUL WITH I WILL HAVE
OUR OWN LOCAL TO LOSE BUT IF THE
STATE COULD FIGURE OUT A SYSTEM
THAT THEY CAN TRAIN US ON INVEST
IN THAT THAT WOULD JUST BE A
LIFESAVER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AND AS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT YOU FOR YOU KNOW BEEN ABLE
TO IDENTIFY SOME OF THE HARD TO
REACH UP POPULATIONS?
THE POTENTIAL INVESTMENT AND
THAT TECHNOLOGY.
HOW WILL HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT
FOR EXAMPLE DUPLICATIONS I'M
WITH [inaudible]
PARTNERS RIGHT SO YOU ALL KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS THE NET YOU'RE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS YOU KNOW
WHAT CENSUS TRACKS YOU'VE BEEN
TO AND YOU HAVEN'T HOW DO WE
ENSURE --
I'M OF OF APPROACH THAT DOESN'T
OFFER DUPLICATION WHEN WE REALLY
NEED THAT COUNT TO BE SUPER
ACCURATE.
SO LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT IS TRYING TO
COORDINATE OTHERCBO'S.
SO --
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY WHICH IS A
HUGE UNDERTAKING I'M JUST
GEOGRAPHICALLY --
AND ALSO WE HAVE URBAN SUBURBAN
AND RURAL AREAS SO IT'S A PRETTY
BIG CHARGE FOR THEM.
BUT THEY SO FAR HAVE BEEN LEAST
--
FORTY FIVE GROUPS AND I'M SURE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THE
HUNDREDS BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
TWENTY TEN AND BY THE TIME THEY
WERE DONE --
A PULLING TOGETHER THE VARIOUS
--
CBS AND THEY'D HAVE HAD --
STRONG SUPPORT FROM CCF AS A
FOUNDATION AND AND I THINK
THEY'LL BE OTHER FOUNDATIONS
THAT WILL STEP UP TO HELP
SUPPORT.
THAT EFFORT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SO THAT'S MORE OR LESS
HOW WE ARE.
GOING TO BE ATTACKING IT AND I
THINK THROUGH THE STATE SORTS
SYSTEM WHICH IS THIS AZRI BASED.
SYSTEM I WILL BE ABLE TO GET
REAL TIME RESPONSE --
AND ARE LA COUNTY --
SYSTEM IS ALSO AS THREE PLATFORM
SO WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO HAVE ALL OF OUR DATA MAPPED
ONTO THE STATE SYSTEM AND WE
WILL BE ABLE TO LOCATE OUR
COUNTY FACILITIES THAT CAN BE
UTILIZED. FOR CENSUS ACTION HE
ASKS AS WELL AS CHURCHES AND
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS SO THERE'S A
LOT OF COORDINATION.
BUT WE HAVE A LONG ROAD AHEAD OF
US SOME OF THE TOOLS WERE
STARTING TO WORK ON AND I THINK
FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
YOU KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND WE WERE
UNDER COUNT IT BY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS SO WE LEARN
SOMETHING FROM THAT EFFORT IN.
TWENTY TEN UP BY REALLY BEING
REAL ABOUT OUR STRATEGY IN OUR
APPROACH WE DID CITYWIDE
TRAINING CITY DEPARTMENTS EVERY
SINGLE EMPLOYEE NOT SITTING
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO THAT IT
ANY SORT OF PUBLIC CONTACT.
WE TRAINED OUR OWN WORKERS WHO
TRAINS OF CBO'S EVERYBODY GOT
TRAINED IN THE SAME WAY UP
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T COORDINATE YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY'S GOT THESE CROSS
RELATIONSHIPS THEY WORK.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT WORK
REGION ONLY --
AND YOU DON'T WANT EVERYBODY
DOING THEIR OWN THING WITHOUT
LETTING OTHER PEOPLE KNOW PAPER
WORKING ON THIS THE FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WORKING ON THE
CONGREGATIONS THAT THERE'S NO
NEED TO OVERLAP AND AND DO THAT.
THERE'S A YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S
NO MONEY LAW AT AS NONE OF US
HAD IN OUR TWENTY TEN A YOU GET
REAL CREATIVE AND YOU DON'T
WASTE YOUR RESOURCES. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY RESOURCES AREN'T REALLY
THE ISSUE IS REALLY THE
COORDINATION AND REALLY THINKING
ABOUT THE MESSAGING THAT HITS
HOME WITH PEOPLE AND IT'S NOT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHETHER YOU
THINK WE HAVE A CRAPPY
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION
THAT'S RACES --
AND TRYING --
TO DEFIED US OR POINT IS MAKING
SURE EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIAN
GETS COUNTED SO THAT WE GET OUR
FAIR SHARE OF ALL THE RESOURCE
IS THE VOICE IN THE
REPRESENTATION THAT WE ARE
ENTITLED.
TO AND THAT'S REALLY YOU KNOW
LIFTING IT UP TO YOU KNOW WE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NEED TO DO
THIS FOR EACH OTHER AND TO LOOK
OUT.
FOR EACH OF OUR COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST SORROW.
TOTALLY AGREE THIS IS A NON
PARTISAN ISSUE IT'S A CALIFORNIA
ISSUE WERE ALL PAYING TAXES AND
AND WE SHOULD RIGHTFULLY GET
THOSE TAXES BACK --
YOU KNOW FOR THE FEDERAL IT TO
FUND THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS --
BASED ON ACCURATE COUNT IN THE
FAIR COUNT OF THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE LIVE HERE SO REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU KNOW WHEN WE NEED TO MERGE
WE STILL NEED TO STAY CREATIVE
LIKE WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
WHEN WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
--
BUT I'D LOVED HEARING ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THEY THAT CAN SAN FRANCISCO IS
DONE AND I'M SURE LA DID --
AND LIKE MR JONES SERVED --
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE THIS SOMETHING FUN
--
AND AND FIND A WAY TO TO SHORE
COMMUNITIES THAT EVERYBODY IS
PARTICIPATING --
TO LOWER THE LEVEL OF ANXIETY
THAT EXISTS AND A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO MAKE PEOPLE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH WITH
PARTICIPATING SO.
I ONE RECOGNIZES SOME NUMBER
IRWIN ON WHO COMMENTS IN GENERAL
ARE NOT GREAT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU PARTICIPATING
LOOKING FOR MANY MORE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY MONTHS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE A LOCAL AND
REGIONAL COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
EFFORTS BY NONPROFITS
[inaudible]
THIS WOMAN.
THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE TO AT
WELCOME UP.
YEAH OR JAN MONTHS WELCOME I
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF NON
PROFITS AS WELL AS JOSEPH THOMAS
MCKELLAR CO DIRECTOR IF PECO
CALIFORNIA FAITH BASED AT
NONPROFIT.
AND I WE WILL HAVE A CHANCE.
YOU START OFF OR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND IT'S
JUST WONDERFUL THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS IS A JOINT HEARING AND I
COULDN'T BE HAPPIER ABOUT THAT.
I'M CHEN MUST FOCUS CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF NON
PROFITS CAO MONTH PROFITS FOR
SHORT.
WE HAVE MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AS
MEMBERS WITH MEMBERS IN FIFTY
SEVEN OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES SO WE'RE KIND OF
EVERYWHERE --
NOT VERY WELL KNOWN IS THAT ONE
IN EVERY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS WORKS FOR A NONPROFIT
FROM CLINICS TO PRESCHOOLS FROM
INNER CITY ARTS TO THE NON HO
HEALTH CLINIC.
FROM THE PTA TO THE SAMOAN
COMMUNITY CENTER.
EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS
BRING IN FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
FROM OUT OF STATE INTO
CALIFORNIA THROUGH FEDERAL
AWARDS FOUNDATION GRANTS SENT IN
AND INDIVIDUAL DONATIONS.
EVERY DAY WE NONPROFIT SEE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRADITIONALLY
UNDER COUNTED THEY COME TO SEE
DOCTORS AND DENTISTS IN OUR
HEALTH CLINICS TO PRAY IN HOUSES
OF WORSHIP TO RECEIVE PROCEEDS
OF OUR FOOD BANKS TO ANSWER THE
DOOR TO A MEALS ON WHEELS
VOLUNTEER.
BUT NONPROFITS ALSO KNOW THAT WE
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO
SUPPORT A COMPLETE COUNT WE ARE
ALREADY THE TRUSTED PARTNERS OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE COME HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COME TO
NONPROFIT FACILITIES EVERYDAY.
FOR EXAMPLE TO NONPROFIT CLINICS
TO WHOM THEY HAVE ALREADY
INTERSTED THEIR HEALTH RECORDS
TO IDENTIFICATION IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS AND THEIR CELL PHONE
NUMBERS.
THEY PICK UP THEIR CHILDREN OF
OUR CHILD CARE SCHOOL PROGRAMS
WE KNOW HOW TO RENT FERRIS
WHEELS [inaudible]
YEAH.
NONPROFITS ARE ALREADY OUT IN
THE BALLOT AND WORKING IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE AN UNDERCOUNT
LOOMS WE ARE ALWAYS GOING DOOR
TO DOOR ANYWAY AND UNDER COUNTED
NEIGHBORHOODS WE KNOW ALL THE
HOMELESS YOUTH BY NAMES.
WE ARE IN THE SMALLEST TOWNS AND
RURAL CALIFORNIA AND WERE
ALREADY VISITING THE HOMELESS
CAMPS THE BOARDING CARE HOMES
THE FARMER FOR HOUSING.
AND THE FAMILIES OF CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES WHEN WE DO
FREE VACCINE CLINICS IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS FOR PETS
CROWDS EMERGED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE ALREADY IN COURT WE CAN
INCORPORATE CENSUS WORKING TO
OUR ONGOING ACTIVITIES RATHER
THAN TO HAVE TO CREATE NEW
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE ADDED ON TO
OUR WORK. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
DELIVERING MEALS TO THE ELDERLY
HANDING OUT SOCKS TO WARM
HOMELESS PEOPLE THROUGH THE
BACKPACKS OF THE CHILDREN IN OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND HAVING YOUNG PEOPLE DO
CENSUS VIDEOS AND ARTS AND
THEATER CLASSES.
NON PROFITS HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
AND EXPERTISE TO BRIDGE CULTURAL
LANGUAGE BARRIERS TO COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO AN UNDERCOUNT.
WE KNOW THE LOCAL ETHNIC MEDIA
WE KNOW THE NEIGHBORHOOD
NEWSLETTERS WE CAN PUT UP
POSTERS TAXED AND SPEAK TO
PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGES.
ARE BOARD MEMBERS EXTEND THE
REACH OF NON PROFITS.
NONPROFITS CAN QUICKLY RECRUIT
THOUSANDS OF ENUMERATORS FROM
THE UNDER EMPLOYED PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE EAGER AND
EAGER TO BE TRAINED TO DO THE
JOB WELL.
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY LEADERS WANT
TO SERVE ON COMMUNICATING AND
CITY COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES
AS I DID IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
TWENTY TEN COMPLETE COMPLETE
CAO.
WE KNOW THAT LEADERS IN UNDER
COUNTY COMMUNITIES CAN BE
RECRUITED TO SERVE ON THEM WHO
KNOW HOW TO PARTICIPATE IN CIVIL
COUGHED CIVIC AFFAIRS AND WANT
TO COMPETE CONNECT.
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO WHAT DO WE NON PROFITS NAY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS WORK THAT WE
ARE PLAINLY QUALIFY TO DO FIRST.
EVEN WHEN FALLING CENSUS OUT
REACH INTO OUR ORDINARY PROGRAMS
WE NEED FUNDING.
WE NEED DOLLARS TO GO TO THE
NONPROFITS WHO HAVE DIRECT REACH
INTO THE NONPROFIT INTO BOOK
THESE COMMUNITIES.
NONPROFITS NEED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENSUS FUNDS AND WE
NEED A PROCESS THAT IS
REASONABLE AND STRAIGHT FORWARD.
GRANTS TO NONPROFITS MUST
INCLUDE ADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR INDIRECT COSTS SINCE COST
INCHES INSURANCE ACCOUNTING AND
HR WILL INCREASE.
FUNDING NEEDS TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFITS WHICH
ARE OFTEN NOT THE LARGE
INSTITUTIONS THOSE A FOR RISEN
FROM RURAL AREAS POOR
COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
ARE IMPACT STUDY BECAUSE
DISCOUNT WHICH YOU'VE JUST
RECEIVED SHOWED THE DISPARITIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE REFLECTED IN
THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
AS JUST ONE EXAMPLE THERE TWICE
AS MANY NON PROFITS PER CAPITA
IN THE BAY AREA AS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN INLAND EMPIRE AREA.
AND BAY AREA NONPROFITS HAVE
TWENTY ONE TIMES.
PER CAPITA MORE DOLLARS THAN NON
PROFITS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED ENUMERATOR JOB
APPLICATIONS AND AREAS
IDENTIFIED AS MOST DESPERATELY
NEEDING ENUMERATORS WE NEED TO
BE CONNECTED TO THE LOCAL
COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEE SO THAT
WE CAN CAN RECRUIT COMMUNITY
LEADERS TO SERVE ON THEM.
WE NEED COLLATERAL THAT CANDIDLY
DOESN'T LOOK OR SOUND LIKE A
GOVERNMENT PAMPHLET THAT'S BEEN
HURRIEDLY TRANSLATED INTO
SPANISH OR CHINESE.
WE NEED TRAINING PROGRAMS WERE
NONPROFITS EAGER TO PARTICIPATE
CAN LEARN DOABLE WAYS TO REACH
PEOPLE THROUGH THEIR EXISTING
SYSTEMS AND VOLUNTEERS.
IN SHORT NONPROFITS ARE READY
EAGER AND UNIQUELY ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE CENSUS WE HAVE A
KNOWLEDGEABLE ENTRUSTED REACHING
TO CALIFORNIA'S UNDER COUNTY
COMMUNITIES BUT NO ONE ELSE CAN
CLAIM WE LOOK FOR TO THIS
CHALLENGE.
I'M UNDER TIME EVEN.
CAME HERE.
EFFICIENCY AT ANOTHER ONE VERY
EXAMPLE FIND EFFICIENCY OF A
NONPROFIT WORLD.
THANK YOU GENESIS.
WELL DONE GOOD MORNING AND ONE
OF THE S. --
IS THE MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA AND ARE FOR HER.
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND OUR
MANY COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU OUR STRATEGY. FOR
ENSURING A COMPLETE COUNT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO MAKE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ABOUT HOW TO BEST DEPLOY YOUR
VALUABLE RESOURCES AND
EXPERTISE.
WE AGREE WITH YOUR ASSESSMENT
THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS IS
OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH HIGH
POPULATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD THAT
ACCORDING TO PRICE WATERHOUSE
COOPERS.
AREAS MOST AFFECTED BY CENSUS
UNDER COUNTING LOSE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER PERSON PER YEAR.
AND FEDERAL FUNDING.
BUT WHAT'S AT STAKE IS AN ONLY
FEDERAL FUNDING.
OR CONGRESSIONAL SEAT
APPORTIONMENT.
WHAT'S AT STAKE IS THE VERY
LEGITIMACY OF GOVERNMENT TO BE A
FORCE FOR EQUITY IN OPPORTUNITY.
HOW THE MOMENT IN HISTORY WHERE
THE VERY QUESTIONS OF WHO IS
HUMAN [inaudible]
WHO BELONGS?
WHO DESERVES A SHARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ARE BEING
CONTESTED?
AT A TIME OF INCREASING DIVISION
AND ANXIETY DRIVEN BY THE
DEMONIZATION OF ONE ANOTHER.
BEING ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CENSUS SENDS A POWERFUL
MESSAGE ABOUT WHO MATTERS.
WE C. THE SENSES IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD BRIDGES
BETWEEN NEIGHBORS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE OUT OF RELATIONSHIP.
AND TO REBUILD THE CONNECTIVE
TISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
AWAKENS PEOPLE TO EACH OTHER'S
HUMANITY.
WE'VE DEVELOPED A FIVE PRONG
STRATEGY TO ENSURE COMPLETE
COUNT IN [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY NUMBER.
ONE INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING AND
GOAL SETTING.
WE SEEK TO INVEST IN UPGRADING
OUR TECHNOLOGY TO IMPLEMENT A
DATA COLLECTION AND TRACKING
SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWS US TO A EFFECTIVELY
TARGET NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL CENSUS
OUTREACH.
BEACH TRACK OUR PROGRESS OVER
TIME.
C. RECRUIT VOLUNTEERS.
AND DE COMMUNICATE REGULARLY
WITH RESIDENTS AND HARD TO COUNT
HER HTC COMMUNITIES.
NUMBER TWO GRASSROOTS
CANVASSERS.
WILL RECRUIT AND TRAIN THOUSANDS
OF GRASSROOTS CANVASSERS AND
VOLUNTEERS FROM HTC COMMUNITIES.
OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLE IS THAT
THE MESSENGER IS AS IMPORTANT AS
THE MESSAGE.
NUMBER THREE BILL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING CAPACITY.
WE SEE THIS CENSUS IS A KEY
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON GOING
ORGANIZING CAPACITY TO ENSURE
RESOURCES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE YEARS AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY ARE REACHING AND
BENEFITING FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
NUMBER FOR LAUNCH A MASSIVE
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING CAMPAIGN.
WE WILL DEPLOY CANVASSERS AND
VOLUNTEERS TO ENGAGE IN AS MUCH
FACE TO FACE RELATIONAL OUTREACH
HOUSE POSSIBLE.
AND NUMBER FIVE THE AIR GAME.
WE MUST EFFECTIVELY DEVELOP
MESSAGING AND EDUCATION
MATERIALS THAT SPEAK TO DIVERSE
CULTURAL AND LANGUAGE GROUPS AND
HTC AREAS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ENGAGED AND
CENSUS MESSAGE PRODUCT OF
RESEARCH PROJECTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY LOS ANGELES AND THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
NUMBER ONE PRIORITIZE RELATIONAL
OUTREACH.
PROFESSOR HARI HONEY UC SANTA
BARBARA.
HAS FOUND THAT RELATIONAL
ORGANIZING IS FORTY TIMES MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN COLD CALLS.
WE'VE LEARNED TO OUR VOTER
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
TARGET VOTERS AND POTENTIAL
VOTERS AND HTC COMMUNITIES.
THAT THE WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
VOTE IS COUNTER INTUITIVELY.
NOT TO LEAD WITH THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT VOTING.
BOTH RATHER A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ABOUT IMAGINING A BETTER FUTURE.
THE SAME APPROACH SHOULD BE
TAKEN WITH THE CENSUS.
NUMBER TWO TRAINING.
STATE FUNDING SHOULD SUPPORT
EXPERIENCE TRAINERS WHO KNOW HOW
TO TEACH CANVASSERS THE
PRINCIPLES OF COMMUNITY BASED
RELATIONAL EQUITY BUILDING.
AND WHO HAVE PRACTICED.
THE GOAL IS NOT TO DRIVE THE BIG
TRANSACTION WERE NOT LOOKING FOR
SURVEY COLLECTORS.
NUMBER THREE RECRUITMENT.
CANVASSERS SHOULD BE RECRUITED
FROM ORGANIZATIONS WITH A TRACK
RECORD OF SUCCESSFUL RELATIONAL
OUTREACH AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING EXPERIENCE.
NUMBER FOUR AS YOU'VE HEARD
ALREADY START AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WE NEED A ROBUST OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION COMPONENT TO START IN
EARLY.
TWENTY NINETEEN IT'S SORT OF GET
READY FOR THE CENSUS CAMPAIGN.
WHICH PLOWS THE GROUND FOR THE
CANVASSERS ONE CENSUS FORMS
BECOME AVAILABLE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THIS PRIMING THE
PUMP IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN IS AS IMPORTANT
AS THE CANVASSERS WORKING.
TWENTY TWENTY NUMBER FIVE
CONTRACTING.
BASED ON LESSONS FROM THE
200-020-0010 CENSUSES
CONTRACTING IN MOST CASES SHOULD
GO THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE CBO'S
NOT CITIES AND COUNTIES.
BECAUSE CBS HAVE A BETTER GRASP
ON THE NONPROFIT LANDSCAPE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AGAIN IN MOST
CASES.
ALSO THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR CBO SHOULD BE AT LEAST
ONEROUS AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
NUMBER SIX DESIGN AND SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ONGOING
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS EFFORT THAT
WILL REQUIRE CLOSE
COLLABORATIONS ACROSS SECTORS
INCLUDING WITH PHILANTHROPY.
SECOND TO LAST NUMBER SEVEN
PROTECT CONFIDENTIALITY OF
INFORMATION OBTAINED EVEN IF IT
MEANS LITIGATION.
AND LASTLY RESOURCES.
MORE RESOURCES WILL LIKELY BE
NEEDED.
WE APPLAUD THE STATE'S NINETY
MILLION DOLLAR INITIAL
INVESTMENT IT'S MORE THAN THE
STATE HAS EVER INVESTED.
AND IT'S LIKELY NOT ENOUGH
[inaudible]
OUR CALCULATIONS WITH C. PAN
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT ALREADY SHOW
A MINIMUM OF ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN MILLION WILL BE NEEDED
JUST FOR CBO OUTREACH ALONE.
THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL NINETY FIVE
MILLION BEYOND THE TWELVE POINT
FIVE MILLION RD ALLOCATED
CBO OUTREACH IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE NONPROFIT SECTOR.
IN THE COMMENTS.
NOT SO. ONE QUESTION I HAVE --
THAT HE E. BOTH TOUCHED UPON
THIS BUT BUT ARE THERE.
ARE HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED EFFORTS
YET [inaudible]
CHIU --
IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
INTERESTED IN TAKING PART.
THERE ARE TAKING THE TEST TO
BECOME FEDERAL CENSUS --
EMPLOYEE NEW ENUMERATORS AND AND
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN FOR A HOW TO
RECRUIT THOSE FOLKS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET THE TRAINING
THEY NEED JUST TO GET THROUGH
THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
LET ALONE ACTUALLY DOING THE
JOB.
HARM WELL EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
ALMOST EVERY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN COMMUNITIES WE
SEE UNDER EMPLOYED PEOPLE MIGHT
JUST UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE BUT OFTEN
UNDEREMPLOYED PEOPLE MAKE THE
MOST READY TO TRAIN --
ENUMERATORS AND HOT AND
NONPROFITS ARE JUST DYING TO BE
ABLE TO SAY TO PEOPLE HERE TAKE
THIS TEST FILL OUT THIS FORM.
YEAH I WOULD ADD THAT COME WE
HAVEN'T YET STARTED ARMED
RECRUITING FOLKS TO BE EMPLOYED
BY THE CENSUS BUT CERTAIN WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO VOLUNTEERS ABOUT
VOLUNTEERING WITH THE SENSES AND
BEING A PART OF THE ARMY OF
CANVASSERS THAT GOES OUT INTO
COMMUNITIES.
THESE ARE FOLKS FROM
CONGREGATIONS FROM COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS FROM SCHOOLS
IN THESE HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH US SINCE AT LEAST.
TWENTY TWELVE DOOR VOTER
ENGAGEMENT WORK.
AND WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
CENSUS WORK BECAUSE THIS ALLOWS
US TO TALK TO EVERYONE AND
HEARTY CAN COMMUNITIES NOT JUST
REGISTERED VOTERS ARE THOSE WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REGISTER
[inaudible]
YOU CAN.
THYROID GET CARRY.
SO I HAVE A BIT OF A CONCERN
WHEN I LOOK AT THE BY RURAL
COMMUNITIES --
MANY THE REAL COMMUNITIES OF AN
BEEN -- LA
FIRES.
AND WE ARE LOSING PEOPLE LEFT
AND RIGHT AND THE NONPROFITS ARE
UNABLE TO PROBABLY PICK UP --
DO YOU HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS ON
WHERE CAN WE GET ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY.
DO THE CENSUS FORCE I'M REALLY
CONCERNED IS THAT --
THE POPULATION THERE I DON'T
THINK SING IT NECESSARY COUNTY.
I THINK THAT NAUNTON ONE OF THE
STRENGTHS OF NONPROFITS IS THAT
WERE IN EVERY COMMUNITY AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER EVEN OUR
MEMBERS ARE IN FIFTY SEVEN OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
AND OUR MEMBERS WHO WERE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS YOU KNOW
ARE ALWAYS STRIVING AROUND --
FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER SO
THEY'RE ALREADY REACHING A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE AND I THINK THAT
THEY'RE VERY WELL POSITIONED TO
DO THAT.
AND AS BECAUSE THEY ARE ALREADY
KNOW A LOT OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
ANNA AGAIN PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
TO THE FOOD BANKS AND OTHER
THINGS.
AYE THEY KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT WOULD BE VERY HAPPY AND
GLAD TO DO THIS WORK OF
ENUMERATION.
AND I THINK THAT SO I ACTUALLY
HAVE A LOT WE SAW IN THE TWENTY
TEN COMMITTEE IN SAN FRANCISCO
--
JUST BE ENORMOUS SUCCESS AND
NONPROFITS RECRUITING
ENUMERATORS NOW THAT'S AN URBAN
AREA.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE IT
WAS ON THE GROUND COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS THAT DID THAT
RECRUITING FOR APPLICATIONS THAT
I THINK WE ARE MUCH MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN SOME OTHER
AREAS.
JUST JUST ONE THING I THINK A
LOT OF THE OTHER PHILANTHROPY
AND LARGE NONPROFITS I TEND TO
BE IN THE METRO AREAS.
AND AND SO I THINK THAT --
I THINK THAT OUR ABILITY TO TO
BE IN EVERY COUNTY WE JUST HAVE
TO GET SOMEBODY FROM ALPINE
COUNTY WILL BE IN --
FIFTY A REALLY GIVES US A UNIQUE
ABILITY TO AT THAT OUR FOCUS IS
GOING TO BE ON THE AREAS OUTSIDE
THE METRO AREAS WHERE THERE'S
LESS REACH FROM OTHER PEOPLE.
AND I WOULD DECIDE ON THAT IN A
BEAT SENSE TWENTY TEN THERE'S
BEEN A MASSIVE INVESTMENT AND
BUILDING COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
CAPACITY IN RURAL AREAS SO.
IN TWENTY TWENTY IT'S ALMOST
NIGHT AND DAY IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS ON THE
GROUND IN PLACES LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE INLAND EMPIRE
--
CUT AND THE NORTH VALLEY OF
SACRAMENTO --
THIS YOU KNOW DEL NORD HUMBLE
COUNTIES KIND OF THE BORDER WITH
OREGON SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A LOT
OF CONFIDENCE AS WELL BASED UPON
SOME OF THE RELATIONSHIPS WE
HAVE WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO FIND.
THAT THE RIGHT PEOPLE --
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN WE HAVE
TO START NOUN IT'S NOT GONNA BE
EASY. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE HEARD --
YOU BOTH OF YOU MENTION IS THE
IDEA THAT.
THIS WORK NEEDS JUST BEGIN NOW
AND AND WE THERE'S ALSO A
CONFIDENCE AND THAT WE CAME
HIGHER -- OR
BRING ONBOARD VOLUNTEERS TO DO
THIS -- CAN
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT
EXACTLY YOU'RE DOING NOW WHO WHY
YOU HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE I GUESS
FROM MY LANDS.
I'M THINKING WE NEED TO DO MORE
NOW -- WE
NEED TO HAVE A POOL OF THE IRA.
OF INDIVIDUALS READY TO GO SET
TO APPLY APPLYING FOR THE NEWMAN
OR AN INTEGRATOR POSITIONS I'M
ALSO KIND OF JUST YOU KNOW A
BENCH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO DO THIS WORK WHAT ARE
NON PROFITS DOING.
RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE RIGHT INDIVIDUALS --
AND I APPRECIATE WHAT WE SHARED
--
A BY MR MCKELLAR.
ABOUT OR THOMAS NUCLEAR --
ABOUT THE PROFESSOR WHO SAID
THAT. FORTY TIMES MORE IT'S
FORTY TIMES MORE EFFECTIVE TO
BUILD A RELATIONSHIP THAN JUST
--
TO HAPPEN ASK --
AND IN A IN A APPRECIATE THAT SO
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
YES SO I AM WE ARE A PART OF THE
TABLE CALLED THE MILLION VOTERS
PROJECT WHICH IS MADE UP OF SOME
OF THE LARGEST STATE NETWORKS OF
CBO'S AND NONPROFITS IN THE
STATE -- WE
ARE WE HAVE KIND OF IN
ORGANIZING PRESENCE AND LOCAL --
ORGANIZING CAPACITY IN THREE
QUARTERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SINCE TWENTY TWELVE WE'VE
BEEN GROWING OUR CAPACITY TO
REACH VOTERS PRIMARILY IN THESE
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES.
THIS YEAR IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILL BE OUR FOURTH CYCLE OF
WHAT'S CALLED AND KIND OF OUR
OUR CIVIC ENGAGEMENT PROGRAMS.
AND SO ON AND SO WE HAVE A TRACK
RECORD OF TAKING FOLKS THROUGH A
TRAINING PROGRAM SENSE.
TWENTY TWELVE IN THE PRINCIPLES
AND PRACTICES OF RELATION BASED
ORGANIZING --
PEOPLE WHO ARE USED TO GOING
DOOR TO DOOR INTO SCHOOLS INTO
CONGREGATIONS INTO BUSINESSES
WHERE PEOPLE IN HEARTS CAN'T
COMMUNITIES LIVE AND WORK.
CONTACT HAVE DEEP CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM ABOUT THE KIND OF
CALIFORNIA THEY WANT TO PASS ON
TO THEIR CHILDREN.
AND WE FIND THAT THAT KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP BASED FACE TO FACE
INTERACTIONS ARE FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE ANECDOTALLY AND THE
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS IT --
THAT PROFESSORS FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA IN YOUR DISTRICT.
MOM SHE'S SHE'S BEEN RESEARCHING
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING SHE'S
AMAZING --
AND SO WHAT WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
ONCE THE ENUMERATOR KIND OF JOB
DESCRIPTIONS AND SORT OF LIKE
THE RECRUITMENT PROCESS BEGINS
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO GET THE
WORD OUT TO A LOT OF FOLKS.
PARTY COME EQUIPPED WITH A SET
OF SKILLS THAT WE NEED FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
I AGREE WITH THAT BUT WE'VE BEEN
CONTACTED BY A NUMBER OF VARIOUS
ASKING TO HELP RECRUIT PEOPLE
FOR COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE THING
THAT WE ARE DOING --
THE BUT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW IF
WE HAD THE MATERIALS NOW WE
COULD START TOMORROW.
WE HAVE THE APPLICATIONS FOR
ENUMERATORS TODAY WE COULD SEND
THEM OUT TOMORROW WE COULD START
SENDING THEM OUT WITH PEOPLE.
NOT JUST THE ORGANIZING
ORGANIZATIONS YOU KNOW LIKE PICO
LIKE VOODOO GREAT JOB BUT ALSO
WITH THE KIND OF THE HUMAN
SERVICE DELIVERY IN THE ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
AYE THAT HAVE A REACH INTO A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
FOR HOW ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
--
GOD I'M LIKING ON BECAUSE I HAD
IT A MINUTE AGO.
SO YOU ALL ARE THAT ARE THE
CLOSEST TO THE COMMUNITIES IN
AND THE CLOSEST --
TO TO THE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
IN AND ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS ONE
THING IS I'VE BEEN TALKING WITH
FOLKS ABOUT THE CENSUS AND
INCLUDING ITS IN THE CAN
MEETINGS THAT THE THE THAT THE
STATE ORGANIZED.
WAS JUST THIS INCREDIBLY HIGH
LEVEL OF ANXIETY THAT EXISTS IN
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ABOUT
PARTICIPATING --
AND AND ONE CONVERSATION PRETTY
WHO WAS WITH LEADERS OF THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY --
WHO YOU KNOW?
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS I TRIED
TO TO REPLY THEY SAID WE KNOW
BUT STILL I CAME BACK WITH YOU
KNOW OTHER DO ALL THE TALKING
POINTS I HAD I EXHAUSTED THE
LIST OF TALKING POINTS I HAD.
AND THEY SAID WE KNOW BUT WE'RE
STILL NOT COMFORTABLE AND I SO
WHAT WILL YOU NEED TO HEAR TO BE
COMFORTABLE AND THEY SAID WE
DON'T KNOW YET.
BUT ONE THE ONE WE HEAR IT ARE
YOU IN A DO YOU HAVE ANY.
ANSWER HERS --
ERROR OR HAVE YOU I'M ASSUMING
YOU'VE BEEN HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES --
THAT YOU WORK WITH ON WHAT DOES
RESONATE WHAT DOES KIND OF GIVE
PEOPLE THE IN THE COMFORT THAT
THEY NEED --
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS.
WELL I THINK JOSEPH'S POINT
ABOUT RELATIONS SOME MONEY YOU
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH MAKES A
BIG DIFFERENCE BUT I ALSO HAVE
TO SAY THAT RIGHT NOW MOST OF
THE MEDIA IS ABOUT ANXIETY ABOUT
THE CENSUS.
WE ARE NOT EMITTING MESSAGES
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE
POSITIVENESS.
OF THE CENSUS AND AS A RESULT I
THINK THAT BY OVER PLANE ANXIETY
WERE ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING TO
INCREASED ANXIETY ABOUT IT.
WE ARE VERY LATE IN GETTING OUT
THE MESSAGES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CENSUS HIVE
SAFETY OF THE CENSUS ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.
YEAH I I WOULD I WOULD REINFORCE
THAT POINT I THINK THAT WE HAVE
A WAYS TO GO STILL AND THEN
BUILDING THE TRUST THAT WE NEED
WITH.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDER ATTACK FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS --
WE THINK THAT YES AS I SAID
EARLIER THE MESSENGER IS AS
IMPORTANT AS THE MESSAGE JUNE --
BUT THE MESSAGE IS GONNA MATTER
AS WELL AND SOME OF THAT IS
BEING.
EXPERIMENTED WITH AS I MENTIONED
THROUGH A A RESEARCH PROJECT
THAT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION --
IS IS FUNDING THE OTHER THING --
IS -- I'VE
SPOKEN TO A FEW FOLKS IT'S IS
THERE A WAY IN WHICH THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED OR IF
STATE DOLLARS ARE USED TO HELP
COLLECT INFORMATION FROM FOLKS
PARTICIPATING THE CENSUS IS
PROPRIETARY IN SOME WAY TO THE
STATE.
THAT THE STATE CAN LIKE USE THAT
AS LEVERAGE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE PRIVACY.
AND TO KNOW THAT THE STATE IS IS
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN LAWSUITS
ISN'T AND ANY KIND OF POWER THAT
THE STATE HOUSE TO MAKE SURE
THEIR INFORMATION IS PROTECTED I
THINK THAT WILL GO SOME WAY.
ONBOARD STILL ALSO LEARNING A
LOT ABOUT WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE AND AND AGAIN IT JUST
REINFORCES THAT THE THE POINT
ABOUT STARTING AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
ABSOLUE THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE LOOK FOR MORE
CONVERSATIONS --
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY MONTHS --
IT SOON NEXT WERE AND MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL PANEL THE ROLE OF
FOUNDATIONS.
IN SUPPORTING A COMPLETE COUNT
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE WITH
US MARICELLA RODRIGUEZ SENIOR
COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
ENDOWMENT NANCY JAMISON
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE SAN
DIEGO GRAHAM MAKERS AND A FRYING
IN ESCOVEDO VICE PRESIDENT
EDUCATION AND IMMIGRATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
AND A MEMBER OF THE STATE'S
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU --
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY -- AND
WHAT WE GO LEFT MY LEFT TO RIGHT
--
MARICELLA IF YOU LIKE YOU CAN
GET OFF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
I'D LIKE TO START BY THINKING
THAT YOUR PERSON LIMON.
PERCENT PAN AND AND TO PERSON
BERMAN FOR BRINGING US TOGETHER
AND CONTINUING AYE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING US THINK
THROUGH HOW BEST TO LEVERAGE THE
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
TOWARDS A COMPLETE COUNT --
AND ALSO LIKE TO NOTE --
THAT LIKE MANY OTHERS I PLAN TO
BE HAS ALSO BEGUN A COORDINATION
UPPER FACILITATED THROUGH GRANT
MAKERS CONCERNED WITH IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES.
OF WHICH THE ENDOWMENT SERVES AS
A CULTURE ROBERT IT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON THE HARD COUNT
POPULATION --
AND UNDERSTANDING HOW THE STATE
PLANS TO LEVERAGE THE NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS WILL HELP ALL
PARKING PARTNERING FOUNDATIONS
FINALIZE OUR STRATEGIC PLANS SO
THERE IS A LOT OF EAGERNESS AN
URGENCY IN UNDERSTANDING HOW THE
STATE PLANS TO MOVE FORWARD --
AND WE'RE PREPARED TO COMPLEMENT
IN SUPPORT AND FILL IN THE GAPS
--
SOME QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY IN DISCUSSIONS INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE WILL THERE BE
PLANNING DOLLARS FOR ON THE
GROUND GROUPS WHAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE AVAILABLE
WE'LL COMMUNICATION FUNDING.
IS LIKELY OF THE CALIFORNIA A
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY FUNDERS
INITIATIVE CONTINUES TO CREATE
ITS QUOTA PLAN TO ALIGN
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING WHILE THE
STATE DETERMINES THE PURPOSE AND
MECHANISMS FOR DISTRIBUTION OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
STATE'S ACTIONS WHILE WE
INITIATE SHORT AND LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS BASED ON THE IMPACT
WE PRIORITIZE TOGETHER.
I ALSO WANTED TO SHARE SOME
LESSONS LEARNED.
UP FROM OUR TWENTY TEN
EVALUATION PERSON SAYS --
SOME STRAINS THAT WERE INTO
IDENTIFIED INCLUDED EFFECTIVE
AND FAR REACHING CANVASSING
ACTIVITIES USE THE MEDIA TO
REACH CERTAIN ISOLATED
POPULATIONS TRUSTED MESSENGERS
TO PROMOTE SENSES PARTICIPATION.
A COMMITMENT TO COOPERATION AND
COORDINATION AMONG MANY GRANTEES
--
I WOULD FURTHER HIGHLIGHT THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY OUR
ORGANIZING NETWORKS IS A
RESOURCE TO REACH THE HARD TO
COUNT.
THEY ARE AUTHENTIC VOICE FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE TO ACHIEVING
A SUCCESSFUL COUNT.
AT THE ENDOWMENT WE PLAN TO
LEVERAGE THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
EXISTS LOCALLY ON THE GROUND AND
YOU YES YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER
TODAY WERE.
A SUPPORTING OUR INTEGRATED
VOTER ENGAGEMENT PARTNERS ARE A
FOURTEEN HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
SITES AMONG OTHER PARTNERS.
AND YOU MAY ALSO HEAR --
FROM -- MY
COLLEAGUES JUST THE IMPORTANCE
AND CONSIDERATION TO GIVE --
YOU KNOW THE FLEXIBILITY.
OF THE NONPROFIT SURE --
AND HOW WE POTENTIALLY HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED GRANTS VERSUS
CONTRACTING --
ON THE COMMUNICATIONS SIDE
BECAUSE THIS IS A KEY AYE
ELEMENT TO PAST EFFORTS ON THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHICH THE
ENDOWMENT SEES AS AN IMPORTANT
--
AS AN IMPORTANT --
THIS IS SIMILAR I EFFORT --
WHERE WE CAN TAKE LESSONS
LEARNED FOR THE SENSES UP
LINDEMANS MEDICAID ENROLLMENT
EFFORTS UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE
INVESTED IN DIRECT OUT REACH WE
MATCHED IT WITH PAID MEDIA?
BUILDINGS SURROUND SOUND TO
AMPLIFY THE VOICES OF THE
ELIGIBLE BUT AN INSURED
INCLUDING MEDIA SOCIAL MEDIA AND
OUR MEDIA.
AND I APPRECIATE THE OTHER
EARLIER COMMENTS ABOUT THINKING
OUT OF THE BOX AND AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO SHARE.
WITH AND TODAY OR IN THE FUTURE
ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DID TO GET OUR CREATIVE AND DO
THINGS OUT OF THE BOX WHICH
INCLUDED THINGS LIKE PARTNERING
WITH BARBER SHOPS AND TACO
TRUCKS AND STREET TEAMS AND
CHURCHES AND OTHER THINGS --
IT AS PART OF OUR OVERALL
COMMUNICATIONS EFFORTS WE
CREATED A SPANISH MEDIA
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF ETHNIC
MEDIA TO ENSURE WE WERE REACHING
A DIVERSE AUDIENCE.
THE ENDOWMENT WILL ONLY HAVE A
SMALL FRACTION OF THAT
INVESTMENT FOR THE SENSES.
OF PHILANTHROPY WILL SUPPORT THE
SENSES IN VARIOUS WAYS BUT A GAP
IN P. MEDIA AS LIKELY TO REMAIN.
AS WE DID WITH OUR EASY IF
EFFORTS WILL BE INVESTING IN
MESSAGE TESTING TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND BARRIERS TRUSTING
MESSENGERS AND MESSAGING TO*
ACCOUNT POPULATIONS.
MESSAGE TESTING IS ALSO AN AREA
WHERE FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER
PARTNERS ARE COORDINATING AND
SHARING INFORMATION.
STARTING EARLY A YOU KNOW JUST
EMPHASIZING THE POINT THAT YOU
HEARD EARLIER TODAY --
STARTING EARLY IS CRITICAL --
WE NEED TO START NORMALIZING THE
CENSUS AND GIVEN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY IS AN ELECTION YEAR WILL
BE A MORE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT.
BUT TO START EARLY AND TO HELP
US NOISE --
SOME NOTES ON GRANT MAKING WE
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC DOLLARS
COME WITH HIGH ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THAT FLEXIBILITY BE MORE MAYBE
MORE CHALLENGING WITH
CONTRACTING SO AGAIN.
CONSIDERING --
GRANTS OVER CONTRACTING WHAT WE
ALSO LEARN FROM TWENTY TEN IS
THAT YOU NEED TO KEEP DOLLARS
AVAILABLE. FOR THE NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW PERIOD SO THAT HOTSPOTS
AREAS THAT HAVE LOWER RESPONSE
SCORES CAN BE REACHED BY
TRUSTING PEOPLE WHEN ENUMERATORS
ARE GOING OUT TO KNOCK ON DOORS.
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE --
AND NONPROFITS ME LATITUDE TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS IN ORDER TO
REACH THE GOAL THEREFORE THE
STATE SHOULD SHOULD AND CAN'T
PLAN FOR FLEXIBILITY AND BILL
THAT ENTERS CONTRACTS AND
GRANTS.
AT THE OUTSET.
IF THERE'S A PLAN TO COLLECT
PERFORMANCE INFORMATION THAT CAN
BE AGGREGATED ACROSS THE REGION
OF THE STATE THIS NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS A NECESSARY.
BUDGET PERSONNEL COSTS AND A
REPORTING PLATFORM MUST BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD FOR USERS TO
USE.
ALSO CONSIDER MULTI YEAR FUNDING
THIS GIVES PARTNER SOME LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY TO PLAN A POTENTIALLY
STOP STOCK UP OR DOWN --
AND LASTLY I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT IT MAY BE HELPFUL --
TO BUT TO TOUCH BASE WITH FOLKS
LIKE COVER CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE
SOME EXPERIENCE WITH THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN THAT
UNDERTAKING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JACOBS MS
AARONSON.
MADAM MINISTER CHAIR SOME
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY UP COMMITTEES THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
BEFORE YOU TODAY ON THIS CRUCIAL
ISSUE THAT WILL SHAPE OUR SHARED
FUTURES.
MY NAME IS NANCY JAMESON I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF PHILANTHROPY
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SAN DIEGO GRANT MAKERS WERE
IN THE PRESIDENT AND CEO.
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS IS A
ONCE IN A DECADE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE AN IMPACT ON THE WELL BEING
OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
AND RECOGNITION OF THE IMPACT
THAT IT.
IN ACCURATE CENSUS WOULD HAVE ON
CALIFORNIA ARE THREE
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGH OUR
ALLIANCE HAVE EMBARKED UPON
FULLY SUPPORTING A FAIR AND
ACCURATE CENSUS COUNT.
AS REGIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATIONS WE CONVENE
PHILANTHROPY WITH OVER SIX
HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
FAMILY COMMUNITY AND PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS CORPORATE GIVING
PROGRAMS GRANT MAKING PUBLIC
CHARITIES AND INDIVIDUAL DONORS.
PHILANTHROPY IS INVESTING IN THE
CENSUS BECAUSE OF ITS CRUCIAL
ROLE IN SHAPING AND FORMING
PUBLIC POLICY.
THE CENSUS PRODUCES DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA THAT GUIDES THE ALLOCATION
OF FEDERAL RESOURCES AND FAIR
POLITICAL REPRESENTATION FUNDERS
RELY ON THE CENSUS DATA. TO
INFORM LONG TERM PLANS AND
GRANTS BY LEADING DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS BUT WHERE TO ALLOCATE
THE RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE SOME
FUNDERS EMPLOYEE CENSUS DATA TO
IDENTIFY COMMUNITY NEEDS.
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS AND GAPS IN
SERVICES.
AS YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS INCLUDE
CHILDREN BETWEEN ZERO AND FIVE
URBAN AND RURAL LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
IMMIGRANT AND MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES AND SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS THESE OUR POPULATIONS
THAT PHILANTHROPY CARES ABOUT.
WE KNOW THAT MANY HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES WILL BE LESS LIKELY
TO FILL OUT THE CENSUS DUE TO
THE INCLUSION.
OF THE NEW QUESTION ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS THAT ASKS
ABOUT US CITIZENSHIP.
THIS SCARE TACTIC WILL RESULT IN
UNRELIABLE DATA FOR THE NEXT
DECADE AND AFFECT THE STATE'S
FAIR SHARE OF FEDERAL RESOURCES.
GLAD TO BE IS ALSO INTERESTED IN
THE CENSUS BECAUSE THE RESOURCES
THAT THE CENSUS BRINGS.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED AND CAL
CENSUS INFORMATION GUIDES
SEVENTY SIX BILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS TO THE STATE WHICH I'M
AMOUNTS TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER PERSON.
THESE FUNDS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICAID SNAP S.
CHIP.
WICK AND HOUSING VOUCHERS. TWO
LARGE SCALE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
LIKE HIGHWAY PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION.
FUNDERS ARE HAPPY AND GRATEFUL
THAT THE STATE IS INVESTING
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES INTO THE
CENSUS.
PUBLIC DOLLARS WILL BE VERY
VALUABLE TO ALL SECTORS THE
RECEIVE SUPPORT TO ENSURE A
COMPLETE AND ACCURATE COUNT.
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM PUNTERS
IS THAT THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
IS SOMETHING THEY'RE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION AS THEY MAKE PLANS
TO INVEST IN THE CENTERS THEM SO
[inaudible]
DOLLARS CANNOT REPLACE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOR THE
CENSUS FROM THE FLAT.
CRITICAL NEED FOR MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE MUNICIPAL
AND LOCAL LEVEL ACROSS THE
STATE.
THUNDERS YOU'RE LOOKING TO THE
PARTICULAR SUPPORT EFFORTS IN
AREAS OUTSIDE OF THE MAJOR
CITIES SUCH AS CENTRAL VALLEY
INLAND EMPIRE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND OTHER
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE WELL
SITUATED TO SERVE AS
INTERMEDIARY HUBS TO BEST
LEVERAGE STATE RESOURCES.
BECAUSE OF WHAT IS AT STAKE FLAT
TO BE HAS TACKLED SEVERAL
EFFORTS TO ENSURE AN ACCURATE
COUNT.
WE HAVE JOINTLY OPPOSE THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S REQUEST
AT CITIZENSHIP QUESTION TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
AND FLAT B. HAS A KEY ROLE TO
PLAY AND LEVERAGING ITS
INFLUENCE COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS
AND DOLLARS TO YIELD A FAIR
COUNT.
CONSEQUENTLY PHILANTHROPIC
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE LAUNCHED THE
CALIFORNIA CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY
FUNDERS INITIATIVE PLAN.
THIS INITIATIVE COORDINATES
FUNDING ACTIVITIES AMONG
FOUNDATIONS AS WELL AS FOCUS IS
ON HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS.
WE COLLABORATE WITH AND RELY ON
TRUSTED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE LOCAL
OUTREACH IN THE COUNTIES.
THIS INITIATIVE ALSO SUPPORTS A
PLANNING OF INDIVIDUAL REGIONAL
HUBS AND HOW THEY COORDINATE
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND WITH
STATEWIDE EFFORTS.
LOCALLY THE BAY AREA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SAN
DIEGO HAVE ALREADY OR WILL
LAUNCH REGIONAL CONVENIENCE AND
EDUCATION ON THIS ISSUE FOR A
LOCAL FUNDERS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE TO
LEVERAGE BOTH PUBLIC AND
PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS TO ENSURE
THAT EACH AND EVERY CALIFORNIAN
IS COUNTED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MISS
REST BETTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
HONORABLE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE VARIOUS COMMITTEES COME
BEING CARE FOR THIS JOINT
HEARING MY NAME'S FY MESCALERO
I'M VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY REGARDING THE
ROLE OF PHILANTHROPY AND
SUPPORTING NON PROFITS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
THIS JOINT HEARING COULD NOT BE
TIMELIER IS CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE IS
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING A STATE
WHITE PLAN FOR DEPLOYING THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT.
OF NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT A COMPLETE COUNT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
SIMILARLY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE AS WE'RE
LEARNING TODAY HAVE BEGUN TO LAY
OUT MORE COMPREHENSIVE PLANS FOR
EFFORTS TO EDUCATE.
ACTIVATE AND ASSESSED HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
GIVEN THE UNPRECEDENTED RISKS
FACING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY SENSES THE
AND PRESIDENTE INVESTMENT OF
NINETY MILLION BY THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
CAN HOW.
FIGHT AGAINST ONE OF THE LARGEST
UNDERCOUNT OF CALIFORNIANS IN
DECADES HOW WHEN WHEN WE
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS WILL
DETERMINE THEIR IMPACT ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
IT'S A PLACE SPACE FOUNDATION
SERVING THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
REGION THE FOUNDATION HAS
SERVED.
OF THE COMMUNITIES OF LA FOR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS OUR
MISSION IS TO HELP BE POSITIVE
SYSTEMIC CHANGE TO STRENGTHEN
LOS ANGELES FOR ALL.
BUT ESPECIALLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THE
FOUNDATION HAS SET ACHIEVING A
COMPLETE COUNT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS AT THE TOP
PRIORITY OVER THE NEXT. TWO
YEARS SPECIFICALLY ENSURING THAT
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES AND POPULATIONS ARE
FULLY RESOURCE.
WE KNOW WE CAN'T DO THIS ALONE
AND WITH LOS ANGELES BEING THE
HARDEST ACCOUNT COMMUNITY IN THE
NATION THIS HERCULEAN GOAL WILL
REQUIRE FULL COORDINATION AND
THE OBVIOUS SUPPORT OF THE
STATE.
MONARCH TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY AND
IN THE COMPANY OF OTHER
COMMITTED PARTNERS IN
PHILANTHROPY.
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY A NARRATIVE
OF COMMITMENT COORDINATION AND
DESIRE FOR COLLABORATION FROM
OUR SECTOR.
WITH MY REMARKS I'D LIKE TO ADD
TO THE CONVERSATION BY SHARING
SOME CONCRETE EXAMPLES.
OF HOW ARE COORDINATION HAS
HELPED MORE LOCALIZED EFFORTS IN
LA COUNTY.
PROVIDING THE STATE IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLES TO CONSIDER AT THE
STATE'S COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE
DEVELOPS A COMPREHENSIVE
INVESTMENT PLAN.
SINCE THE START OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA FUNDER GROUP.
THAT'S BEEN REFERENCE HERE TODAY
IN THIS CHAIRED BY THE JAMES
IRVINE FOUNDATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
OUR GROUP NOW GOING TO OVER
THIRTY FOUNDATIONS OF LOCAL AND
STATE AND WITH VARYING MISSIONS
IN PRIORITIES HAVE ALIGNED WITH
THE COMMON GOAL OF A COMPLETE
COUNT.
AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY THE
GROUP'S CURRENT EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN FROM MY
COLLEAGUE MONEY SELA AT THE
ENDOWMENT.
AND ABOUT OUR GOAL TO ENSURE
STRONG ALIGNMENT WITH THE STATE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THAT STATE AND LOCAL AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
PHILANTHROPY HAS PLAYED A
SUPPORTING ROLE IN EARLY SENSE
HAS EFFORTS IN LARGE PART THANKS
TO OUR WORK TOGETHER.
AS A FUNDERS GROUP.
AND NOW LAY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER PARTNERS
LIKE THE WEINGART FOUNDATION
HAVE BEEN WORKING AT A LOCAL
LEVEL.
WITH COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND CITY TO
SUPPORT THESE PLANNING EFFORTS
TO DATE.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITYFOUNDATION
HAS INVESTED NEARLY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT JUST PLANNING
AND LOCAL RESEARCH EFFORTS.
THIS SUPPORT IS INCLUDED THE
FOLLOWING.
HELPING TO CONVENE WITH THE
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK A
LOCAL REGIONAL GROUP OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS NOW FORM
THING CALLED REFERRED TO AS THE
ALLEY CENSUS REGIONAL TABLE.
PROVIDING THE ALEX CENSUS
REGIONAL TABLE PLANNING GRANT TO
DEVELOP A COMMUNITY DRIVEN OUT
REACH PLAN IN COORDINATION WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS COMPLETE
CAO COMMITTEE.
INVESTING IN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FIELD AND
OPINION RESEARCH GRANTS
DEDICATED TO DEVELOPING BASELINE
DATA ON HARD TO COUNT
DEMOGRAPHICS.
THIS WORK IS ALSO HOPING TO
INFORM THE WORK OF THE STATE'S
MESSAGE TESTING WORKING GROUP.
BEING AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COUNTY CITY COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE TO WHICH MEANS WE
REGULARLY ATTEND.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT THE DECISION
TO SUPPORT PLANNING AND RESEARCH
WAS A PRODUCT OF OUR
COORDINATION WITH STATE FUNDERS
AS IT'S WHAT SET AT THE TOP.
EARLY PRIORITY FOR OUR
PHILANTHROPIC INVESTMENT.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS THAT
STATE.
HUNG THIS THAT THE STATE WOULD
DEVELOP ITS PLAN FOR INVESTING
SETS ITS FUNDING I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT THIS BE THIS
PLAN.
BE CENTERED ON HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES IN POPULATIONS WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT IF WE
DESIGN.
OUR EFFORTS AROUND THE EXTREME
USER.
FIRST WE WILL.
AROUND THE EXTREME USER FIRST WE
WILL ACHIEVE A TRULY INCLUSIVE
EFFORT.
AND THE LAST PART OF MY REMARKS
I'D LIKE TO REITERATE AND AT TO
THE PRINCIPLES WE HAVE SHARED
WITH YOU TODAY.
OUR DESIRE IN SHARING THESE
PRINCIPLES IS TO SHAPE THE
PRINCIPLES THE STATE WILL ADOPT.
IN IT STATEWIDE PLAN
[inaudible]
SO FIRST.
STRENGTHENED DON'T JUST STRETCH
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR.
PHILANTHROPY HAS LEARNED THAT
NONPROFITS ARE PRECIOUS RESOURCE
THAT NEEDS TO BE SUSTAINED AND
NOT JUST DEPLETED FUNDING SHOULD
TAKE CARE TO ENSURE THAT AFTER
YOUR PROJECT WE ARE LEAVING A
STRONGER RESOURCE BEHIND FOR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. TO
FUNDING SHOULD TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THAT THIS IS A MULTI FACETED
ENDEAVOR.
THIS MEANS HAVING A RANGE OF
ALLOWABLE ACTIVITIES AND SUPPORT
ROBUST OUTREACH.
INCLUDING LOCAL ICE COMMUNITY
RELEVANT RESEARCH.
CAPACITY SLASH INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDING TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE COALITION BUILT
COALITION BUILDING ACTIVITIES.
DIRECT CONTACT IN RELATIONAL
ORGANIZING ACTIVITIES AND ALSO
NARRATIVE BUILDING A DEEPER
COMMUNICATIONS WORK BEYOND I
JUST ADVERTISEMENT. THREE
PROVIDE AGILE FUNDING WOULD
RECOMMEND GRANTS NOT CONTRACTS
ACCOUNTABILITY CAN BE ACHIEVED
FOR CLEAR DETAILED GRANT
AGREEMENTS.
AND ALSO IN THIS AGILE FUNDING
TO ALLOW FOR MORE ROBUST SET.
PARTNERS THAT CAN BE FUNDED
GRANT SHOULD HAVE FLEXIBILITY
THAT RECOGNIZES THE ENVIRONMENT
IS SHIFTING AND ORGANIZATIONS
MUST CREATE.
AND INTEGRATE CENSUS WORK INTO
THEIR EXISTING COMMUNITY WORK
IT'S THROUGH THIS WORK THAT THE
TRUST WE NEED REALLY EXIST AND
FINALLY.
BE COLLABORATIVE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT WITH REPORTING ANY
EVALUATION DATA WILL ABOUND FROM
MANY SOURCES AS WE'VE HEARD.
BEING OPEN TO WHAT YOU HAVE NEED
AND CAN SHARE ONE ENSURE WE HAVE
A FULL PICTURE OF OUR PROGRESS
IN NEEDS.
I HOPE THAT OUR PRESENCE HERE
THIS MORNING DEMONSTRATE
PHILANTHROPIES ENGAGEMENT AND
DESIRE TO COORDINATE.
I AM PARTNERING I URGE YOU TO BE
SPEEDY AND SHAPING THE STATE
PLAN A WELL INFORMED
PHILANTHROPIC SECTOR WILL HELP
TO AMPLIFY AND EXPAND OUR
COLLECTIVE IMPACT OF THE STATE.
HOWEVER IT WILL BE HARD TO PLAN
IF DETAILS OF THIS INVESTMENT
ARE UNCLEAR OR DELAYED WE'RE
HERE TO WORK FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THIS LONG THANK YOU I THINK YOU
IT'S IT'S BEEN A GREAT TO HEAR
ALL THREE PANELS AND THERE'S
DEFINITELY MENTS
THEMES THAT YOU'VE ALL KIND OF
SHARED IN THERE'S ELEMENTS.
AND THAT ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
I GUESS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS NOW
HAVING HEARD ALL THREE AND YOU
THREE HAPPENED TO BE THE ONES
THAT ARE HERE TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION --
BUT SO IS THAT THERE WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF OF OF ERROR IT
TONE OF KIND OF THE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS MADE A NINETY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT --
AND I HEARD.
IT KIND OF LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
AND GOVERNMENTS MAKE A CASE AS
TO WHY.
THEY ARE INEFFECTIVE AND ENTITY
TO KIND OF TAKE ON SOME OF THE
FUNDING I HEARD THE NON PROFITS
TO THE SAME AND I'M HEARING
FOUNDATIONS DO THE SAME.
SO NOW MY QUESTION IS IS A WHAT.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHO IS THE
RIGHT?
WHERE IS THE RIGHT PLACE TO MAKE
THE FINANCIAL INVESTMENT AND WHO
IS NOT -- SO
NOT JUST HERE'S WHY THE FOUNDING
WOULD BE GREAT WELL WAIT A GREAT
PLACE TO MAKE THAT INVESTMENT
BUT HOW DO WE KNOW.
WHERE IT'S NOT A GOOD PLACE TO
MAKE THE INVESTMENT AS WELL?
RIGHT OUT CERTAIN ASSURE THAT
I'M.
THERE'S NOT ONE SINGLE PLACE TO
MAKE THE INVESTMENT SO THERE'S A
ROLE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
PLAY WHEN IT COMES --
TO THE WORKING HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES I THINK WHAT YOU'LL
HEAR SOME OF US SAY --
AND AND HOPEFULLY BUILD UPON IS
I'M.
OUR RELATIONSHIPS AND OUR
FUNDING.
IS BASED ON DECADES OF
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING WITH
NONPROFITS UNDERSTANDING THOSE
NEEDS AND AND BUILDING AND
SUPPORTING.
OTHER SUCCESS AT WORK AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO I'M AS FAR AS TO
WHO TO FIND THEM WHERE TO PUT IT
I THINK IT'S ABOUT.
WHERE IS THERE ARE GENUINE
COMMUNITY DRIVEN ENGAGEMENT AND
THEN WORKING WITH PHILANTHROPY
TO UNDERSTAND --
WHO ARE NONPROFIT PARTNERS THAT
WE MAYBE DON'T SEE IN IN OUR AYE
FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT BUT I
WOULD SAY THE REASON A LOT OF IT
FOCUSES BACK TO THE STATE IS
BECAUSE IT ALL BEGINS WITH THE
TEMPLE THAT THE STATE SETS?
IF THE NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
ARE PUT INTO VERY RESTRICTIVE
CONTRACTS ONE WE GOTTA TRY TO
WORK AND ENGAGE NONPROFITS WE
WILL BE HAVING.
TO INVEST RESOURCES TO HELP
MITIGATE AND HAVE THEM MEET
THOSE OBLIGATIONS VERSES HOW DO
YOU EXPAND AND DEEPEN YOUR WORK
AND SO.
IT'S IT'S TAKING THE STATE'S
LEAD IN THE SENSE THAT THE WAY
THAT THESE GRANTS IN THIS MONEY
GOES OUT TO THE COMMUNITY.
WALL EITHER HELP US TO AMPLIFY
AND EXPAND THE WORK OR CAN SORT
OF CREATE A HINDRANCE FOR US
WHERE WE PUT OUR MONEY.
SO A LOT OF IT IS LAST ON
DIRECTING WHERE YOU SHOULD PUT
THE MONEY BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE IN A NUMBER
OF AREAS NONPROFIT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT MORE ON HOW YOU STRUCTURE
THIS MONEY IS GOING TO DICTATE.
HOW NONPROFITS PERFORM AND HOW
WE CAN THEN LEVERAGE THAT TO
BUILD UPON THAT MORE I HOPE
THAT?
KIND OF ADDRESSES [inaudible]
SOME AMERICAN.
SURE ARE GONNA.
THIS IS A CROSS SECTOR PROBLEM
THE MINUTE WE ALL OF US NEED TO
STEP UP AND DO OUR PART --
AND BUT THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY THE NONPROFITS TO THE
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN REFERENCED HERE MANY
TIMES ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND THAT'S
WHERE THE THE ENERGY OF THE
RESOURCES THE WORK IS REALLY CAN
BE DONE AND COMMUNITY --
ON A PHILANTHROPIC PERSPECTIVE
WE CONVENE --
INVEST AND THAT YOU KNOW
LEVERAGE YOU KNOW COMING HERE
WITH THE STATE GOES THERE AND
PLAY SOME ACTIVATION ROLE --
FOR THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
YET ACTIVATED SO HERE WORSE HAVE
A TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP IN THE
PHILANTHROPIC SECTOR IS HERE
TODAY AND LARGE --
FOUNDATIONS AND FOUNDATIONS OF
SIGNIFICANCE ARE SITTING AT THE
TABLE TRYING TO MAKE THIS WORK
HAPPEN.
THERE'S MORE PHILANTHROPY OUT
THERE THAT IS NOT QUITE --
UP TO SPEED ON THIS YET AND
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF OUR JOB
AS PARTICULAR POSSIBLE TRUE AND
SOME OF THE HARDEST ACCOUNT --
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE --
AS MUCH ATTENTION LOCALLY TO
THIS AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE TALKED
A LOT ABOUT THAT WHEN WE GET WE
ARE GOING TO DO TO HELP THOSE
COMMUNITIES --
ACTIVATE WHATEVER IT TAKES
DEPEND ON THE REALITIES IN THE
NATURE OF THAT PARTICULAR PLACE
I'M TO GET THE MONEY OUT ON THE
ENERGY ON THE WORK DONE IN THE
VOICE -- AND
THE WORD OUT --
TO GET DISCOUNT DONE.
NO JUST ECHO MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS AND I WOULD JUST SAY NO
THAT THIS IS BOTH IN TERMS OF
LIKE HOW.
HOW WE INVEST BUT IT'S ALSO
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH YOUR NEW
NOT ONLY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHO
GETS THE MONEY BUT HOW IT GETS
DISTRIBUTED WHETHER IT'S?
DIRECT ON THE GROUND OUTREACH
VERSUS COMMUNICATION AND WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE FROM PAST
EXPERIENCE WEATHERS THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT OR ANYTHING
ELSE YOU WANT TO LOOK AT IT HAS
TO BE A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
YOU THE STATE WILL HAVE.
MORE RESOURCES THAN WE WILL HAVE
TOGETHER SO I THINK THAT'S WHY
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KNOW.
HOW THE STATE'S LEVERAGING THOSE
RESOURCES SUPPORTIVE AND
COMPLIMENTARY?
AND I THINK I WOULD ALSO ECHO
THAT -- YOU
WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AT POPULATION
IN REGION AND SOME COMMENTS
EARLIER THAT REMAIN --
THERE MAY BE SOME INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT AREN'T AS STRONG AS IN
OTHER REGIONS AND YOU MAY ALSO
WANT TO LOOK AT THAT --
AND ALSO LOOK AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS A PLACE I MAY GO UNDER
INVESTED.
AND THE THE IMPORTANT THING IS
--
AND YOU'RE HEARING IT HERE TODAY
IS WE'RE NOT STARTING AT ZERO
RIGHT SO YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT.
MILLION VOTERS PROJECT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE WORK ACCOUNT
NUMBER THERE'S PIPELINES ON HOW
YOU GET.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF RESOURCES
INTO VERY LOCAL COMMUNITIES FOR
IMPACT THERE'S PIPELINES THERE'S
MAJOR STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE PICO CALIFORNIA CALLS
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT.
THAT ARE SET UP TO FUNNEL THAT
WAY COUNT NONPROFITS AND SO.
A KEY PART IS WE'RE NOT STARTING
ZERO THERE'S ACTUALLY PIPELINE
SOMEHOW YOU MOVE SUPPORT INTO
THESE AREAS AND WILL BE KEY FOR
THE STATE.
STITCH INTO THAT AND AND WORK
ITS PLAN IN THAT WAY RATHER THAN
TRYING TO CREATE.
OTHER WAYS.
CRAIG AND I AND I DO APPRECIATE
THAT I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
--
EATS IN I THINK YOU HAD THE
COMMENT THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
INVEST IN EXISTING.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE MODELS ARE
MODELS AS OPPOSED TO CREATING
NEW ONES AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
I'M A POWERFUL THING I THINK IT
SPEAKS TO THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE BUT ALSO INTO THE ABILITY.
TO TAKE THAT THESE POTENTIAL
FUNDS -- AND
USE THEM IN A WAY THAT'S
EXPANSIVE THAT SUPPLEMENTS I'M
THE WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEING
DOING AS OPPOSED TO NEO --
AND I KNOW YOU WERE ALL VERY
CAREFUL THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY
SHOULD GO YOU DID NOT TELL ME
WHERE THE MONEY SHOULD NOT GO
AND SO I STILL LEAVE THAT
QUESTION OUT THERE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF IT
KNOWING YOU KNOW YES WHERE
POTENTIAL MONEY SHOULD GO.
BUT WE'RE SHOULDN'T NAKO I THINK
THAT THAT'S THE CLOSEST WE GOT
PERHAPS YOU KNOW BEING.
I'M A LITTLE THOUGHTFUL AND
WHETHER WHERE IT'S GOING TO
PLACES THAT DON'T HAVE A HISTORY
OF BEING ABLE TO GENERATE.
THE OUTCOMES WERE LOOKING FOR
ESPECIALLY IF THE STATE CONSIDER
SOMETHING LIKE A GRANT VERSUS A
CONTRACT MODEL AND I THINK FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE IN SEEN THE
PUBLIC FUNDS AS WE JUST WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN ALL IS SAID AND
DONE --
DEPTH IN THE MAJOR AND THE
HISTORIC INVESTMENT AT THE STATE
IS MAKING IS ONE THAT ON THE
YIELD THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AND THAT'S THE FEAR
IT'S NOT THE FEAR THAT THESE
NONPROFITS --
ORGANIZATIONS ARE MUNICIPALITIES
WOULDN'T DO GOOD WORK WITH IT ON
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE
SO MUCH AT STAKE AND HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE INVESTMENT
THAT THE PUBLIC THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
IS MAKING INTO THIS INITIATIVE
YIELD SOME OF THE OUTCOMES AND
THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR IN A IN
A REALLY HARD TIME IN A TIME
WHERE --
YELL A A A A JUST PEOPLE ARE
VERY SENSITIVE TO ANYONE --
KNOCKING ON THEIR DOOR ASKING
ANY INFORMATION I MEAN EVEN IF
IT'S A STUDENTS SELLING YOU KNOW
THEIR FUND RAISING THING FOR THE
SCHOOL PEOPLE ARE REALLY HAS A
TENT RIGHT NOW.
INFORMATION OR GIVE OUT
INFORMATION AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT I'M A THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AND IT JUST ECHO THOSE THANKS
I'VE BEEN SO IMPRESSED BY THE
ENGAGEMENT FROM OF PHILANTHROPIC
SECTOR --
AND IT WAS ALMOST A YEAR AGO
THAT I WAS TALKING I'VE BEEN SET
UP WITH SOMEBODY --
TO TALK ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION
ISSUES AND AFTERWARDS THIS THIS
GENTLEMAN ASKED ME WHAT ELSE HE
WORKING ON I SAID ALL I JUST
BECAME CHAIR OF A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE CENSUS.
AND AND HE SAID REALLY THAT'S
FASCINATING YOU KNOW TOMMY MORE
AND THEN HE SAID CAN I CONNECT
YOU WITH WITH THE EXECUTOR ACTOR
MY FOUNDATION IN --
MAD LOVE FOR YOU THAT TO TELL
HER ABOUT IT AND SO HE MADE THE
CONNECTION AND THEN SHE
IMMEDIATELY REPLIED WERE ALREADY
WORKING ON HE THIS IT IS HADN'T
BEEN KINDA MADE AWARE OF THAT
YEAH AND THAT THAT SHOWS THAT
THE PHONE TOPIC SECTOR.
HAS REALLY ENGAGED EARLY AT THE
SAME TIME THE PHILANTHROPIC
SECTOR IS SUCH A BIG SECTOR --
AND AS I TALK TO DIFFERENT
FOUNDATION --
MAYBE MAYBE IT'S THE LEADERS OF
THE FOUNDATIONS KNOW WHAT WHAT
EVERYONE IS DOING BUT THE THE
THE FUNDERS.
DON'T NECESSARILY SO --
MYSTERIOUS AND YOU YOU MENTIONED
HOW THERE'S A NETWORK OF
PHILANTHROPY'S BETTER
COORDINATING IS ARE YOU ALL ARE
YOU ALL --
KEEPING TRACK OF WHO'S
DOING WHAT --
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT COMING
UP WITH WITH THE BIG NEEDS LIST
THAT YOU SEE FROM A
PHILANTHROPIC SECTOR AND THEN
MAKING SURE THAT IF AND
FOUNDATIONS --
FILLING IN THOSE GAPS THAT MAYBE
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT THAT COORDINATION IS SORT
OF THE ESSENCE OF WHAT WE DO FOR
BIG ISSUES ARE.
IT IS --
MORE ROBUST TO MATURE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE'S
THAN OTHERS I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT LOS ANGELES TODAY AND
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO.
THOSE --
CENTERS OF PHILANTHROPY --
IN BIG WAYS IT'S A LOT OF A
MAJOR FLAP IS THAT OR HAVE
ALREADY CREATED TABLES ARE
TALKING TO EACH OF THE STATE
WHITE TABLE IS THERE'S HANGING
OUT UP TOGETHER THERE AND TRYING
TO COORDINATE.
THAT LEADERSHIP THAT IS BEING --
HAS BEEN FORMED IS GOING TO
TRICKLE DOWN AND CONNECTS TO THE
REST OF THE STATE THROUGH FLAT
TO BE CALIFORNIA THE ALLIANCE OF
THE THREE REGIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE IN THE STATE OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE FOUNDATIONS
IS HERE WE NO WE DON'T REINVENT
THE WHEEL THAT FUNDERS NEED TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER AND THAT
THEIR WHAT THEY DO NEEDS TO BE.
DEEPLY INFORMED OF WHAT'S GOING
ON THE GROUND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE DOING THE WORK SO --
THE STRUCTURE IS THERE THAT
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE A LITTLE
SOONER IN SOME PLACES AND OTHERS
WHICH SOME WE NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND AS WE CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT
THE STRUCTURE.
GREAT AND A AYE IF I HEARD
CORRECTLY FROM FROM.
MULTIPLE SPEAKERS TODAY THERE'S
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE
WHERE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT
NOT NECESSARILY EXIST WITH IT
THAT.
DONOR DATABASE DOESN'T EXIST TO
THE CBO COMMITTEE ISN'T AS
STRONG AND I WRITE THAT THAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS A A BIG AREA
OF OF KIND OF CONCERNED --
NEED -- FOR
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
IN FOCUS ARE THERE OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT THAT YOU ALL
OF IDENTIFIED.
INLAND VALLEY INLAND EMPIRE
IMPERIAL COUNTY OKAY.
VERY HELPFUL NO --
AND CAN I ADD A LEADING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY --
ALSO HAD THE POINT ABOUT FIRE
STRICKEN OR NATURAL DISASTER
STRICKEN AREAS WHERE --
WE'VE LOST A LOT OF RESIDENTS IN
HOMES AND COUNTING THOSE FOLKS
WHO MAY BE MOVING AROUND IS
MAYBE SOMETHING ELSE TO PUT ON A
GREATER.
THERE'S WORK GOING ON NOW WITH
OUR COLLEAGUE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GRANT MAKERS THAT IS
INVOLVED IN TALKING TO FUNDERS
AND ABOUT THE FIRES THERE
LINKING IT TO THE HOW THAT'S
GOING TO IMPACT THE CENSUS
THEY'VE STARTED THAT WORK
[inaudible]
PERFECT [inaudible]
ETHNIC.
REALLY GETTING INTO.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT --
SORE GONNA MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND I THINK [inaudible]
NOTE [inaudible]
I THINK.
I'M JAN THAT'S OKAY YOU ME IF IF
YOU WANT TO START OFF PUBLIC
COMING BECAUSE I THINK YOU MAY
HAVE HAD SOMETHING TO ADD.
ABOUT WHERE THE MONEY SHOULD NOT
GO AND I'D LOVE TO HEAR THAT.
I THINK IT'S ONLY PARTLY ABOUT
WHO GETS THE MONEY AND IT'S WHAT
ACTIVITIES GET THE MONEY.
TRADITIONALLY HAVE TO SAY THAT
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT IN FRANCE A
PM IF YOU USE THE ANALOGY OF A
GUY LIKE READY AIM FIRE
TRADITIONALLY PHILANTHROPY
GOVERNMENT.
HAVE BEEN KIND OF READY AIM AIM
AIM AIM AIM.
HIGH AND MAYBE WE ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR MIGHT FIRE
BEFORE WE TAKE CAREFUL AIM BUT I
THINK IF WE DON'T HAVE TIME. TO
BUILD UP INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO
RESEARCH TO REVIVE DEVELOP PLANS
AND THEN REVISED PLANS AND THEN
REVISE PLANTS AGAIN.
WE SHOULD CUT MY MY ANTI PLAN WE
WANT TO DO THAT BUT WE CAN'T
WAIT TO ALREADY START THE OUT
REACH.
ALREADY START DOING THIS WORK --
WE CAN'T WAIT AS LONG AS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SO WE NEED TO
INVEST PARTLY IN PLANNING BUT
MORE IN GETTING OFF THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A AND NEXT
UP WE HAVE ELEMENT TOMORROW FROM
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. FOR A
LITTLE BIT LONGER THE COUNTIES
IN A CLEAR.
THANK YOU --
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS AND
SELECT COMMITTEES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR THEIR INSIGHTS I'M
ELLIE MATSUMURA WITH THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA.
AND YOU KNOW THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT WE FONTS BEFORE
BRINGING TO THE TABLE AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS THAT UNPARALLELED
EXISTING CAPACITY TO REACH OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
WE HAVE TWENTY THOUSAND COUNTY
EMPLOYEES THERE ARE VERY FEW
RESIDENTS IN A GIVEN YEAR WHO
DON'T INTERACT WITH THE COUNTY.
OUR HOSPITAL ALONE PROVIDES CARE
ONE IN FOUR RESIDENTS --
TO SAY NOTHING OF THE CLINIC THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS ASSESSOR CAL
WORKS SNAP OF PUBLIC SAFETY
LIBRARIES PARKS HEALTHCARE
SERVICES PROBATION YOU GET THE
IDEA NOT POTENTIAL GROWS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE --
WITH THE CITY OF SAN JOSE WHO'S
REALLY BEEN OUT ON FRONT ON THE
CENSUS --
WE'VE ALREADY CONVENES THREE
DOZEN TOP LEVEL CROSS SECTOR
LEADERS AS OUR PLANNING
COMMITTEE FOR THE CCC --
FOR SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH
LAUNCH AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OUR STAFF AND PARTNERS THAT
HUNDREDS OF NONPROFIT PARTNERS
THAT WE CANNOT CONTACT WITH.
EVERY YEAR THESE RELATIONSHIPS
REALLY DO GO DEEP INTO HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES
SO WE KNOW THE PEOPLE WE KNOW
THE PARTNERS WE KNOW THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND AND WERE READY
TO MOBILIZE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS WE WILL
BE BRINGING TO OUR BOARD A
DETAILED STRATEGIC PLAN A TO
PROPOSE TO THEM FOR HOW WE
LEVERAGE AND COMPLEMENT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THAT INCLUDES PROPOSALS FOR
SOME ORIGINAL RESEARCH ON SOME
SOME GAPS WE'D LIKE TO FILL IN
REALLY UNDERSTANDING HOW WE BEST
TARGET AND REACH T. HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE BEEN
IN CONVERSATION WITH THE
PHILANTHROPY COMMUNITY ABOUT
THIS AS WELL --
WE INCLUDE ROLES FOR STAFF
POSITIONS AND FOR HOW WE
COLLABORATE WITH.
AND SUPPORT OUR COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE.
IT ALSO ADDRESSES HOW WE CAN
STEP UP TO MEET THE CENSUS
WORKFORCE NEEDS WE HAVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED TO
MOBILIZE AND BUILD UPON --
INCLUDING CONSIDERING HOW WE
MAKE SOME OF THOSE SHORT TERM
JOBS MRE ATTRACTIVE BY THINKING
ABOUT CREATING A PIPELINE FOR
THOSE TRAINED ENUMERATORS AND
OUTREACH WORKERS ON THE BACK AND
TO BE ABLE TO PLUG INTO JOBS FOR
THOSE SKILLS.
CAN BENEFIT SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO'VE BEEN
SPEAKING TODAY --
AS WELL AS OTHER BUSINESSES AND
PARTNERS STRENGTHENING OUR
COMMUNITY AND LOCAL ECONOMY --
IN OUR PLAN ALSO INCLUDES OUR
COST PROJECTIONS OVER THE THREE
FISCAL YEARS ON THAT THIS IS
GOING TO SPANS OF THAT WE WE CAN
CARRY ALL OF THAT OUT.
OF AND REALLY LEVERAGE WHAT
WE'VE GOT.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO AND TO
SHARING THIS PLAN AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I NEXT UP WE HAVE LINDA CUTLER
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
I'M REALLY ACTUALLY WEARING TWO
HATS ONE IS AND THE CEO OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION.
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND I'M
PERSONALLY.
PROUD CONSTITUENT OF DOCTOR PANS
--
BUT IN SACRAMENTO --
WE ARE HE HAS A SACRAMENTO
REGION.
THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO WE ALSO
REPRESENT YOLO SO.
I MISS CURRIES --
OF AB CONSTITUENTS AS WELL AND
STAND IT'S WE HAVE AN
INTERESTING --
MIX OF URBAN AND RURAL AND I
JUST WANNA SAY ON BEHALF OF OUR
PLASTERED ALL DORADO.
WE ARE FULLY AND AND WANT TO
WORK VERY HARD IN THIS REGION TO
ADDRESS ALL OF OUR HARD TO KILL
POPULATION.
BUT I'M MORE RELEVANT TO TODAY
I'M HERE IS THE CHAIR OF THE
EAST A LEGAL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS.
AND I WANT TO THANK ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
FOR ITS LEADERSHIP.
AND REALLY --
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO THE
LEAGUE AND THE LEAGUE HAS IN
TURN MADE THIS AN INITIATIVE AND
A KEY PRIORITY.
WE REPRESENT --
THIRTY TWO COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHICH
REPRESENT ABOUT 95%.
OF THE OF THE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AS COMMUNITY.
FOUNDATION FOUNDATIONS WE HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF REALLY WORKING
VERY CAREFUL VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS A NONPROFIT.
SO I'M REALLY JUST HERE TO SIX
TO SAY THAT.
THE LEAGUE IS HERE TO WORK WITH
FRANCE WE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ENDOWMENT WITH WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE THAT THIS COUNT
COUNTS AND I'M SO PLEASE PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT WORK HERE AS A
PARTNER --
WE CLEARLY KNOW HOW TO DO
FUNDING I JUST WANT.
TO REITERATE MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
AND AGILITY AND THE FUNDING AND
AGAIN WHAT WOULD COME DOWN ON
THE SIDE OF GRANTS VERSUS CON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE AT JUDI ROBINSON
FROM COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO A
SEGMENT OF WHICH IS SAID.
NO GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY
NAME IS JUDY ROBINSON ON THE
CENSUS MANAGER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
I'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
WILL AND THAT COMMITTEE STAFF A
SELECT COMMITTEE STAFF ONLY SIN
AND CHRIS WEGMAN AS WELL AS MY
COUNTERPARTS ON ELIAN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
AND IN THE GONZALEZ WHO'S GOING
TO PRESENT AFTER ME I FROM SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND OF COURSE
DOROTHY APART FROM LOS ANGELES
--
GOVERNMENT IS COORDINATING
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO THE
FIRST THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
REASSURE YOU IS THAT.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DOES NOT WANT
THE FUNDS TO DISTRIBUTE ALL THE
CONTRACT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WAS WHY WE'VE
REACHED OUT TO OUR SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY REGION FOUNDATION.
AND SAID YOU ARE THE RIGHT FOLKS
TO BE DOING THIS NOT ONLY THAT
BUT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY IN AN
ENGAGING OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY HAVEN'T
ON THUS FAR FOR WHAT FOR A
REGARDLESS OF OF DIFFERENT
REASONS --
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO DO THIS AND AND AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS IS A A
COMMUNITY LED INITIATIVE IN
ORDER FOR IT TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THIS REALLY HAS TO BE BY AND OF
THE COMMUNITY CERTAINLY WITHOUT
YOU KNOW WORDS GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPORTING A IN ALL SECTORS AND
CERTAINLY WORD WORRIED
LEVERAGING OUR CONTRACTS AND AND
OTHER WORK THAT GOVERNMENT DOES.
BUT THIS NEEDS TO BE SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE ARE SO MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT WORK THE CENSUS IS
HUGE BUT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT UP ON OUTCOMES THAT
THEY CAN COME FROM THIS GOING
FORWARD AND THEN I KNOW THAT
THAT'S PART OF WHAT.
WHAT DID ISN'T SOARED WANTS TO
BUILD BUT ARMED --
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND OUR REGION
FOUNDATIONS WILL NOT BE DOING
THE SAME THING WE ARE WALKING
LOCKSTEP ARMINE ARMINE WORKING
TOGETHER SUPPORTING EACH OTHER
--
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE DO HAVE
THE RIGHT FOLKS AT THE TABLE.
BUT I WANT IT WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE I'M NOT I THINK THIS
OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN'S
OPENING COMMENTS IS THAT NOT ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE OF THE SAME.
AND WHERE OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE SOME LARGER
FOUNDATIONS AND HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES FROM THOSE FOUNDATIONS
TO BE DOING.
SOME OF THE EARLY COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AS THAT WAS PART OF
LUKA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY SACRAMENTO WE DON'T
HAVE A LARGE FOUNDATION AND AND
LINDA DIDN'T MENTION IT.
BUT I'VE BEEN BANGING ON DOORS
AND TRYING TO CONVENE MEETINGS A
WE NEED SOME FUNDING APPEARANCE
SO -- I DO
HAVE IN ASKING THE ASK IS
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH OTHER
LARGER FOUNDATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
--
YOU KNOW OR OTHER FUNDING THAT
MIGHT BE OUT THERE IT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE SPREAD THROUGH OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT LACK
THOSE RESOURCES YOU ALREADY KNOW
THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER
--
BUT WE REALLY DO NEED FINANCIAL
SUPPLY ARMS SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
PASS THAT THROUGH TO OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
DO THIS NECESSARY WORK BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS OF THE
CAPACITY SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE A DOROTHY JOHNSON
FROM C. SAC FOLLOWING AND I
GONZALEZ FROM SAN MATEO COUNTY.
I START TO GET THE LINE APPEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOTHING IF THE
OPPORTUNITY DOROTHY JOHNSON OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES INCLUDING
ALPINE AND WE JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR P. APPRECIATION FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY AND ALSO ARE.
A HOW MUCH WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AS A
PARTNER IN A RESOURCE TO
DISTRIBUTE INFORMATION ALL THE
COUNTIES.
WE KNOWS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND I AGAIN LOOK FOR TO THIS
BEING THE HI MY NAME IS EMMA
GONZALEZ AND I WITH THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATEO.
A CENSUS MANAGER I'M HERE TODAY
TO TH ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR EFFORT AND
CONTINUED SUPPORT IN THIS HOME
AS WE UNDERGO THE CENSUS. FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN DAYS
LEFT THAT'S WHAT I LOOK AT
EVERYDAY WHEN I GET TO WORK.
AND THAT BECAUSE SAN MATEO
COUNTY IN WEARING A UNIQUE
LOCATION WHERE SENATE RIGHT
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND SANTA
CLARA.
I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS WITH MY SURROUNDING
PARTNERS I THINK IN MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED WE SIT
ON A BI WEEKLY CALLED WITH.
SACRAMENTO SAN JOSE OR SAN JOSE
SANTA CLARA.
AND LOS ANGELES AND THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AS WELL AND THE
COUNTY.
WE DO THAT BECAUSE WE SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF REGIONAL
COLLABORATION WE ALL HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IS.
LESSONS LEARNED AND BEST
PRACTICES.
AS LA COUNTY IS MOVING FORWARD
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THAT THEY
WERE WANTING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
WE CAN COLLABORATE.
SENATOR COUNTIES COMPRISED OF
TWENTY CITIES. 38% OF OUR
POPULATION ARE IMMIGRANTS WHAT
THE OVER A HUNDRED OF FORTY
LANGUAGES SPOKEN.
THAT TAKES STRONG COLLABORATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING WE
JUST COMPLETED A CENSUS COUNT
WHERE WE GOT ENOUGH.
OF LOOK ABOUT CENSUS COUNT LUKA
--
AND WORKING WITH CONNECT LAPSED
VALLEY FOUNDATION THINK THAT YOU
TO THEIR EFFORTS.
WITH THAT WE RECEIVED A NET GAIN
OF SIXTEEN THOUSAND HOMES WE
DIDN'T TIRE CANVASSING OF EAST
PALO ALTO.
WHICH REQUIRED AND WORKED WITH
OUR NONPROFITS BUT THAT AGAIN TO
COLLABORATION AND THAT'S THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE COUNTIES
CAN BRING.
BUT WE HEAR YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LIKE TO WALK AWAY
WITH.
IS REALLY STRESSING THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT THE COUNTIES PLATE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT'LL CUT
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S OUR ROLES COUNTY AND
BRING IN ALL THOSE PARTNERS
TOGETHER AND ASSURING THAT WE
HAVE AN ACCURATE COUNT. FOR
AGAIN AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN DAYS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THING KILL.
ANDREW MEDINA FOLLOWED BY HOST A
FINA AND NOT SEEN I HOPE I
PRONOUNCED THAT RIGHT.
COURAGE MEDINA OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA REMEMBER OF DEFENSE'S
POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK OUT JUST
MADE UP OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SERVED HEART CAN'T COMMUNITIES
WOMEN ADVOCATING TERMS OF MORE
SUPPORT FOR SUCH AS PUTTING OUT
REACH.
AT VIRTUALLY THE BUDGET --
SO TODAY'S WANTED UPLIFT CHAN
AND JOSEPH COMMENTS TODAY IN
TERMS OF REALLY STRESSING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT ARE CBO'S NONPROFITS HAVE
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE.
UNDERGROUND AND AND HOW BELT
THAT IS I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
IF YOU BILLION PARTY TED TED.
MITCHELL DOESN'T OF THE FUNDING
AROUND HE'S COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU SERVICE
SMALLER POPULATIONS AND I DO YOU
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COMMENT FROM
PARKS HAVE GONE TO COMMUNITIES.
THEY COULD BE HERE TODAY --
FOR THE NOTE A LOT CANCER
PUBLISHES WOULD NOT ME LUCKY'S
IDLING LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AND BECAUSE OF THE
THRESHOLDS SONY NOTED ON IT THAT
WORKS IN PUBLIC AND DAM.
ANALYTICAL TO COMPETENCY WORKS
AND FALL ON THAT GREAT CITY
DOING HIS RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO REACH OUT TO THESE
COMMUNITIES.
UP FOR ASIAN AMERICANS THAT'S
JUST CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR FOR
LA OFFICE OF THE RAND ECAC
COUNTS WHICH WAS A STATEWIDE
NETWORK WORKING ON COMPLETE
COUNTY TWENTY TEN WHICH INVOLVED
ABOUT SOMEONE ORGANIZATIONS SET
IT ON THE GROUND WALKS.
UP TO DOORS THAT PHONE BANKING
IN LANGUAGE AND TOOK LANGUAGE
MATERIALS AND TRANSLATE TO ABOUT
EIGHTEEN LANGUAGES INVOLVING
FORTY THREE TRANSLATIONS I
WORKED WITH ETHNIC MEDIA TO
PROVIDE.
A IN LANGUAGE AND OUR REACH A
DISTORTED BUT THEY'VE WORKED
THAT IT'S KIND ABOUT THAT IN
TERMS OF WHAT CAN NEED BE NEEDED
TO BE DONE.
ON THE GROUND A ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS SO --
IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT AND PARTICULARLY FOR
NINE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CPR WHICH WE REALLY VITAL AS
WELL AS ALSO THINKING ABOUT WHAT
NEXT YEAR CAN LOOK LIKE.
BY CALVINISTIC BUDGET NO NORTH
TO HEAR ABOUT NEXT YEAR --
BY THE ONE I LIKE THAT AS WELL
SO I'M THINKING WHAT YOUR TIME
AND THEY ALSO DID WANTING ME TO
FIGHT FLEXIBILITY.
OF THE NINETY POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AS WE KNOW
NEITHER MENTIONED ABOUT HOW CAN
WE REACH IS REALLY SPECIFIC
SMALLER COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THINK I WAS HAVING THAT I'M IS
NOTS NOW WITH CHILDREN NOW ALSO
A MEMBER OF SEE PAN.
THANK YOU ALL FOR WORKING WITH
US AND I'M BEING A PARTNER --
WANTED TO JUST MAKE THE POINT TO
UP LEFT --
THE HAVE IMPORTANT IN THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE COMPLEX AND
ENSURE THAT ALL EFFORTS
RECOGNIZED THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE NEARLY A PART OF EVERY HARD
TO REACH OUR POPULATION.
I'M SO THAT ANY COMMUNICATIONS
AND OUTREACH I'M STRATEGIES I
SHOULD REFLECT AND EMPHASIZE --
THE YOU KNOW THAT THE NEED TO
COUNT YOUNG CHILDREN CALIFORNIA
HAS NINE MILLION CHILDREN.
OUT OF THREE MILLION OF THOSE
ARE EIGHT ZERO TO FIVE I'M AND I
THINK THE THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION
TODAY BY THE DIFFERENT OUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND FOUNDATIONS --
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ALL THE OF THOSE --
AT FOCUS IS ON ON COMMITTEES
THAT ARE HARD TO COUNT ALSO THAT
WE'RE NOT REINVENTING THE WHEEL
THAT THERE'S BEEN GREAT GRANT
PROGRAMS LIKE THE OUTCOME OF
CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAM THE ONE
CALIFORNIA GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THAT
CAN BE LEARNED AND THAT WE CAN
REPLICATE IN FILLING OUT THOSE
FUNDS THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
AT WE HAVE SANTOSH SERENE SANTA
AND AND NOW LOOK BECAUSE SHE OUT
FOLLOWED BY JOE MICHAEL.
AND WE WE WELL WE DO HAVE A THIS
ASSEMBLY HEARING A SESSION FLOOR
SESSION THAT STARTS AT ONE
O'CLOCK SO I JUST WANNA.
MAKE SURE FOLKS ARE AWARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M
CENTER CERAM SANTANA WHAT
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
WE ARE CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
LOCATED IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
CHINATOWN AND AS MISS PAWN
REFERENCE ONE OF THE HARDEST
ACCOUNT IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SO WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
CENSUS A EVERY DECENNIAL CENSUS
FOR THE LAST FIVE DECADES AND
THAT EXPERIENCE HAS TAUGHT US
MANY THINGS --
SOME OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO ONE REALLY
PAY ATTENTION TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
NOT JUST COMMUNITY BASED
ARGUMENT NOT JUST NONPROFITS OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THAT REACH
AND DEPTH AND LANGUAGE SKILLS TO
REACH THOSE HARDER TO REACH.
SO REALLY LOOK UP LIFT THEM AS
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT FUNDING.
ALSO WHETHER THAT FUNDING IS
CHANNELED THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC
FOUNDATIONS OR GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES THAT.
THOSE DOLLARS NITA FLOW DIRECTLY
TO LOCAL NONPROFIT GROUPS LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NOT AN INTERMEDIARY.
AND FINALLY I WOULD SAY
PORTANTINO --
TO START EARLY GET THOSE DOLLARS
OUT HIS LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THEY HAVE TO HIRE
TRAIN SCALE UP GET THOSE DOLLARS
OUT AND MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT WAY THERE'S CONTINUITY OF
KEY STAFF THEY CAN LEVERAGE
THOSE DOLLARS AND IT'S NOT A
TWELFTH MONTH GRANT PERIOD WHERE
THEY HAVE TO START ALL OVER
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THINKING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GOAL E. A.
YANG I KNOW THE SPELLING
PROBABLY THERE YOU ARE FLY AND
AND I'M WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER ALSO
KNOWN AS C. RACK.
AND WE WORK WITH OVER --
TWENTY FIVE SOUTHEAST ASIAN
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHICH INCLUDES AND
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND LONG BEACH IN ORANGE
COUNTY THE BAY AREA AND ALSO
EATING BICU COUNTY.
AND AND JUST WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE MY COLLEAGUE BEFORE ME
AND TO REALLY ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FINALLY THAT FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENSURE.
THAT I ARE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES ARE I'M A PART OF
THE COMPLETE CAO.
WITH SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICANS
WE HAVE REALLY --
HIGH RATES OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A LOW
EDUCATION ATTAINMENT.
AND A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES ALSO
LIVE IN RURAL COUNTIES --
AND SO IT REALLY MAKES OUR TO
REACH AND SO WE'RE REALLY
RELYING ON AND THE DECISION TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDING GOES INTO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO ARE READY SERVE THE
POPULATION AND NEED THE
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO BEEF UP THEIR AFFECT
THEIR CAPACITY --
TO DO CENSUS OUT REACH AND
ENGAGE AT THE KILL.
AND FOLLOWING THAT JOE MICHAEL
IS GINA JUST SILVA AND TO ADD TO
NET AS ANY BUTTON.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE MICHAEL FOR
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WHERE ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CENSUS POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK OUT KEEP THIS
BRIEF CAUSE I KNOW YOU ALL NEED
TO GET GOING --
BUT JUST WANTED TO ALIGN WITH
THE COMMENTS FROM OTHER MEMBERS
OF SEE PAN AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
THAT STRATEGIC USE OF THIS
FUNDING I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ALL BRING EVERYONE TOGETHER TO
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION TODAY THINK
THIS IS TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT.
AND I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT THAT
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS THE THING I
WAS SAYING LGBTQ PEOPLE ARE PART
OF ALL MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA PRETTY NEARLY.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH THE
REPRESENTATION AND THE CENSUS OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY WILL NOT BE
WHAT WE HOPE IT WILL BE ONE DAY
WE STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE TURNING OUT AND ARE
PARTICIPATING AND WANT TO BE
HELPFUL AYE TO THAT YOU AGREE
THAT WE CAN.
IN MOBILIZING THE COMMUNITY
SOUTH THANKS LOS MUCH.
IDIDN'T SLEEP A THEME WITH
MALTA AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER.
ALSO A THANK YOU FOR ALL AYE.
HEARINGS THAT WE HAD IN THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SECURITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
A STAND THAT WE REALLY DO NEED.
TRACKED FUNDING GOING STRAIGHT
TO CBO DOES NOT HAVE AN
INTERMEDIARY ON MUCH WE'RE GONNA
REALLY NEED TO START EARLY.
THE CENSUS GIVEN THAT WE DO HAVE
SOME KIND.
STERN AND HOW THAT'S GOING TO
PLAY OUT AND IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
CHARGING WHAT THAT MIGHT MEAN
FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT
COMMITTEE PEACE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE --
THOSE NONTRADITIONAL A LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY THE INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF ANY SPECIFIC --
A RESOURCES TO EVEN OUT REACH TO
SOME OF THESE UNWRITTEN
LANGUAGES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY --
AND I WAS VERY THANKFUL THAT AB
THERE IS SOME BUILT IN
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FUNDING THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT BUILT
IN FLEXIBILITY GIVEN THAT WE
DON'T KNOW.
WHAT OTHER POLICIES ARE POLICY
CHANGES MIGHT BE COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHAT IMPACT
IT'S GOING TO HAVE?
ON IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ON
FOREIGN WHITE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
AND DO WE HAVE JEAN AT THE SAVA.
UP GOTCHA OKAY INSTEAD GOT IT
IRATE SO SEEN NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAIRS
[inaudible]
BEFORE.
THERE ANY CLOSING COMES ON A
DAY.
ALRIGHT WELL I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE TO TESTIFIED AND SPOKE
I KNOW MY STUFF Y. HAD A POP IN
AND OUT FOR OTHER COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AS WELL I KNOW MY STAFF
FIVE HERE'S BEEN TAKING COPIOUS
NOTES AND THAT.
YOU AND I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE
--
THE VERY IMPORTANT ROLE ACTION
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT CRITICAL
ROLE NONPROFITS WILL PLAY AND
THE SUCCESSFUL CENSUS AND I WANT
TO THANK.
US ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON OWN --
FOR HELPING US GREEN THIS
HEARING TODAY AND OF COURSE --
SOME EVER BERMAN MY COUNTERPART
AND ASSEMBLY AS WE ARE LOOKS TO
HAVING A SUCCESSFUL TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR UP TO STATION --
JUST LACK OF THE COMMENTS OF OF
CENTER PAN --
I'VE BEEN HEARTENED BY THE THE
RECOGNITION BY EVERYBODY
BIPARTISAN NONPARTISAN IN ACROSS
ALL INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE.
OF THE CENSUS AND OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A COMPLETE COUNT
FOR CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY TWENTY
AND REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYBODY
WHO'S PARTICIPATED IN THE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
SACRAMENTO.
IN THE CAN MEETINGS THAT WE'VE
HAD ACROSS THE STATE --
IN CONVERSATIONS THAT DOCTOR
PAIN AND I HAVE HAD WITH
DIFFERENT GROUPS --
EH.
ACROSS THE STATE ALSO ACTUALLY A
OF THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AND
I'M SURE THAT'S GOING TO RAMP UP
A LOT OF THE NEXT AND IT WAS
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN DAYS
--
GOVERNOR'S. SEVENTY NINE NINETY
SEVEN FIVE HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
DAYS -- AND
IT'S REALLY GONNA TAKE A TEAM
EFFORT OF THE PHILANTHROPIC
SECTOR THAT CBO COMMUNITY THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR --
GOVERNMENT AT THE STATE LEVEL
THE COUNTY LEVEL THE CITY LEVEL
--
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COVER ALL. THIRTY NINE
TO FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE HAVE --
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER --
JUST A QUICK NOTE THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY --
WHICH IS THE UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION OVER OUR SINCE
EFFORT HAS ASKED THAT I
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE STARTING
TO DEVELOP A FUNDING FORMULA
THAT WILL INFORM IMPART THE
ALLOCATION OF DOLLARS TO
NONPROFITS AND CBO'S.
AND AN EFFORT TO BETTER INFORM
THIS PROCESS THE AGENCY WILL BE
RELEASING A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS SO PLEASE STAY TUNED.
WHATEVER THIS IS RELEASE OWL
ADDED -- TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ANNOUNCED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA AND I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES
CENTER PANEL AS WELL ON THE
SENATE SIDE --
AND VILLAGES ONE THANK EVERYBODY
--
ALL THE PARTICIPANTS FOR JOINING
US TODAY AND AND LASTLY TURN IT
OVER TO AS A MEMBER LIMON.
THANK YOU I WANNA I THINK CHAIRS
PAN IN CHAIRS BERMAN I'M FOR
CONVENING THIS I THINK THAT THE
FACT THAT YOU SEE TWO HOUSES
HERE BOTH SENATE AND ASSEMBLY --
TOGETHER WITH THREE DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES --
A COMING TOGETHER IS REALLY --
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT EMPHASIZES
HOW MUCH THIS ISSUE MEANS TO THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO ON I
THINK THAT ALL THOSE AYE WHO
CONVENE THIS ALL THOSE THAT
WORKED ON THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF.
ALL OF THE PRISONERS AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE FROM COMING
FROM ALL DIFFERENT PLACES I
THINK YOUR MESSAGES WERE LOUD
AND CLEAR I'M WE HEARD A LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT KNOWS THAT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL.
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE
FLEXIBILITY --
AND THAT --
OUR APPROACH HAS TO BE
MULTIFACETED NOT JUST LOOKING AT
MUNICIPALITIES OR COUNTIES BUT
ALSO CBO'S AND NONPROFITS
ALTOGETHER.
THAT WE HEARD THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT.
THESE ENTITIES OF THAT THAT
COORDINATION HAS STARTED OUT WE
ALSO HEARD A MULTIPLE TIMES HOW
POOR AND GRANTS WHERE VERSUS
CONTRACT.
YOU ALL DID MANAGE TO COORDINATE
THAT MESSAGE WELL THIS IS THE
LAND THAT HE AS WELL AS AT IN
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENT --
IS AN INVESTMENT THAT GOES INTO
--
EXISTING EFFORTS THAT HAVE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD --
AND AND I THINK THAT THAT WAS
IMPORTANT WE ALSO KNOW THAT AT
THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE HARD TO
REACH IN THOSE AREAS I'M INCLUDE
THE INLAND EMPIRE --
THAT IMPERIAL COUNTY CENTRAL
VALLEY RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
FIRE STRICKEN AREAS --
AND I THINK THAT ALL OF THESE
MESSAGE ALONG WITH THE MULTITUDE
OF DETAILS THAT ARE REALLY GONNA
HELP INFORM --
AND MOVED THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD I DO WANNA AGAIN THINK
THE CHAIRS OF THE CENSUS
COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES A FOR
INCLUDING THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
ON IN THIS CASE IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND NOW YOU MUST
HAVE A MORE ROBUST.
I'M DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD AS THE STATE'S A THANK
YOU.
AND WITH THAT I I JUST WANNA.
A TERM THAT I LEARNED THAT I HAD
AND USE AS MUCH BEFORE THE I'M A
START USING UP LEFT.
THE COMMENTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF CHAIR LOW MOAN --
ABOUT THINKING OUR STATUS --
BECAUSE THERE'S SIX OF US A LEFT
APPEAR ON THE DYESS BUT ONLY
THREE OF US DID A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT LED TO TODAY THE OF
THE THREE OF US SHOWED UP --
AND SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND I KNOW --
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM AS WELL AS US THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEETING ADJOURNED